i'm playing mikko thank you daniel
i'm [ __ ] nervous though man
are you grand master we're getting close we're
knocking on the door only 2 000 more chess rating
thanks good is 2000 a lot in chess it's about
20 years worth of perfecting and practice
yeah 2000 is a lot
to go from 100 to three thousand that's
like your whole life dedicated to chess
yeah it is fun kraken thanks to the resub scholar
i know who jay and silent bob are it's clerks
yeah we watched it last night uzi it's pretty wild
getting [ __ ] nervous man
thanks for the bits done
i said 2 000 more rating
which would put me at 3 100.
also 2000 is literally by definition
not trash level 2k is [ __ ] huge
what's the reason diddy
play mikko's bot to get ready
does she oh she does have a bot how do i play
well i'm going to keep this up then actually
i'll play miko's bot where's your bot i don't
think i've ever played a bot is it on computer
oh here we go
uh this is this is fine
no not the not the right one
that's dangerously close i wonder
if she's gonna push that up
you know what i'm just gonna develop bishop
here just out of curiosity no she didn't
i want to take up the center right
why didn't she take back
i gotta be honest i don't exactly know
what's going on but i'll i'll take it uh
this is so weird um do i even
want a castle or should i just
immediately start looking for a
mate here which i think i can get
let's just let's just go wild
um
damn i can't push that yet
damn
oh i don't know why i did
that i tunnel vision too hard
whoops
seems fine to me
what should i take with your bishop or knight
or do i just want to deliver the check first
so many [ __ ] options i'm taking with the knight
that that's the one that makes the most sense
to
uh
it was made if i had taken there that wasn't made
oh it would have been actually yeah
cause this was cut off you're right
yeah damn you were right now i can't
do this because the bishop's there
so if i had just played that that would
have been made you're absolutely right
put them back maybe she'll just repeat moves
why can't i find this mate
this
where the [ __ ] is it
i feel like this should be such an
easy mate but i absolutely i mean
it would have been if i had just taken like
i said but i feel like i'm still missing it
i mean i could just start taking pieces
but i'd much rather actually find this
all right let's just go wild i take here you can't
take one i mean you can't take back but i can't
do that because of the bishop still if i can get
that bishop off though what would be the next play
it's not gonna work
let's just chase queen
where was that [ __ ] mate from before
and we are back with day three for pogchamps three
presented by grip6 with me is the one and only the
man him the legend i would say the myth but you're
the prophet that's what you go by these days
i suppose i do well it's an honor to be here
danny i'm so excited for these matchups we've got
some absolutely mouth or mouthwatering matchups
today i can't wait uh to dig into these games
well uh right there with you and it's it's uh
it's an honor as well your grandmaster daniel
neroditsky for those who don't know of the legend
but uh we'll talk a little bit of course about why
you were nicknamed the prophet at some point on
the show today because fate would have it that
uh your your student is playing so let's let's
jump in and remind everybody of all 16 of the
participants before we break down today's specific
match-ups uh let me just ask you donna we're now
three days in and you've been watching as a fan
just like all of us it's been an exciting moment
or an exciting player of all 16 of them in front
of you that maybe caught your eye or surprised you
at all with their with their strength i've
been glued to the screen danny and lots of
these players are they're so aggressive logic in
particular uh caught my eye of course there was a
scare that he survived with the mouse lip and of
course sardoche the uh legend of his work ethic
has gone the world round uh so we'll be keeping
a close eye on him and of course mr beast just
because of how huge he is i'm just very curious to
see how he'll handle the pressure of jess and of
course xbc he has improved tremendously so i'll
be excited to see how he uh his performance in
pogchamps three so lots of players to uh look out
for and uh very interesting games today as well
and of course moist them not gonna lie 100
percent see how mr beast making his debut today
um along with uh along with moyes his return here
to pogchamp so uh all right yeah we'll get into
all that let's remind everybody the format you see
we still we already got a lot of you hanging with
us whatever platform you're choosing to watch from
thanks for being here uh the format is of course
four groups of four the players will play a
double round robin which in chess terms means
you play with each color white and black you get
three points for an outright match win two if it
takes tie breaks to win and then one point goes
to the person who lost in tie breaks armageddon if
it goes to that then of course the top two players
from each group advance to either the championship
or top two advance to the championship bracket
the bottom two advance to the consolation bracket
and the bracket stage is single elimination the
prices are bigger than ever donya i know you got
that memo but it's 100k now up from 50k here
in the third edition and even more importantly
we have a community element we've been raising
money throughout and i'm sure we're going to hit
our goal i believe in it let's go ahead and bring
up the community graphic to remind everybody of
where we stand currently and we will uh remind
you of how you how you can get involved in help
we're also going to remind you where you can
go to see the different charities that the
players have chosen a lot of you've been asking
of that and we'll let you know all the different
charities uh that you could donate for if
your favorite player ends up winning uh so
gonna be awesome donya the uh the charity
element i'm super excited to see where we
get and this is where we currently stand in
terms of the groups and what we've seen so far
indeed danny so much at stake here and love to
see the community outreach as we have a bird's eye
view of some of the match-ups here as we discussed
so many interesting players uh these groups will
be hotly contested and uh that's going to continue
with uh today's matchup stand yeah and let's uh
let's look at that so as you said we've got code
miko uh the v tuber rockin the first match of the
day versus moist critical uh charlie is is uh
one of the fan favorites for crazy moments in
the first pog champs and he's back here in pog3
and it's going to be awesome to see i know i you
mentioned xqc of course who has improved a ton we
know that charlie has also improved a ton budwig
was streaming a bunch of chess last night that
matchup versus him and mr beast is is is frankly
i think what most people are super pumped seated
that doesn't take anything away from anybody but
it's partly because of their their banter we'll
get into that in a minute in fact right there in
fact daniel did you see this go down on twitter
just moments ago between mr beast and ludwig
i did not danny am i reading this right i'll
give you 10 000 if you do so what is hope you
don't mind me taking your king today these are
some fighting words danny they're getting into it
before the first move is made that's what i love
to see i love it they've been getting into it all
all i guess lead up to the event they've had some
they've had some pretty funny moments back and
forth and uh i i think ludd is serious we know
that he throws money down sometimes although we
also know that he says things that are completely
ridiculous like the fact that he goes to chess.com
to beat the danny bot and you are welcome blood
to upload that on twitter the moment you uh
show that you you beat the dannybot anytime buddy
all right but moving on let's remind everybody of
another huge event coming up with our partners at
twitch on march 2nd it's our next twitch rivals
and chess.com partnered event this time it's
going to be hand in brain it's going to be awesome
they've just announced that the next twitch rivals
will be featuring some of your favorite creators
ludwig voyboy the boteslive hicaro they're playing
hand in brain and i actually have a real-time
update from one of the leads at twitch right
now uh then it's actually thirty five thousand
dollars in prices not twenty five thousand and uh
it will take place on march second i can't wait
um and uh i think i think you might be there
as well donna were you are you involved in that
uh i think so i mean i'll definitely uh
make time and i love hand and brain it's
such a good spin on the game and it always
results in really really fun chess so i'm
really looking forward to that danny that'll be
march 2nd 1pm pacific start time i can't wait
for that either yeah it's going to be a big
hand in brain is so much so much fun you pair
different levels of chess and and then let the
cards fall where they may before we jump back
into today's specific matchups another shout out
to gaia ki yerba mate of course we want to take
a moment to thank our sponsors for all of our
sponsors for pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
but right now talking about gaia key as they
celebrate 25 years of your favorite regenerative
yerba mate they're sharing cases to celebrate spam
the gaia key emote in chat for your chance to win
and we will be back after after a very quick
break to start the first matches of the day
four pillars of regeneration to heal all nations
we work with and not against because we are a
part of this we've never been apart from
this our hands feel through the soils past
our feet touch on the blades of grass raid all
these voices into a beautiful tapestry find those
similarities we all share in these breaths that we
breathe this home of ours sustains us but needs us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire us all to come to life
i will fill out the game with time to think
but honestly honestly honestly guys chess is just
a game anyway it doesn't doesn't mean anything it
doesn't mean anything okay chess is just a game um
it's not like everyone's gonna remember this game
i mean probably people probably won't to
be honest people probably really won't
we will all right my my chat might but but but
but you know but you know the rest of the world
won't so you know it'll be like
it will be like it never happened
okay if nobody remembers it does
it mean it actually happened oh
oh if no one remembers it
doesn't actually mean it existed
i say no
all right guys i'm gonna get ready
for ultimate humiliation although i am into it
i am into it so uh maybe maybe it's it'll be
a fun thing um all right let's see the score
okay okay log into okay got it whoa one
being my gifting 10 tier one cells lucky
subs for play for we currently
definitely need we definitely need it
i am at chess.com live mr chess
thank you thank you slight delay three
more minutes ah three more minutes
ah charlie will destroy you i'm into it
i'm into it destroy me charlie
make me feel you wrecking my pieces
this is the most action i've
gotten in the last eight months
last three weeks do it wreck me i can't
wait what do you mean out of context
what why are you guys wearing champagne
you're oh wait wait what is your opponent
what is my ass when you tell me my ass what
was it what my odds are 1 to 23. you guys
if you bet on me and i win you'll become a
millionaire do you know that if you just bet
a hundred dollars on me you
will get 23 100 times 23.
100 times like 20 23 23. 2 300.
jesus yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about magic time
we're in the game
uh
watch that video all day i know what's going on
your head bob your head it's all right pretty good
hype video i was that was awesome i was vibing to
that but i'm going to be biting into the games too
well the games are about to start any second the
the team is ready the players are ready we saw
uh code miko talking about how if someone had
just put 100 bucks on her maybe they'd become a
millionaire when she when she wins the whole thing
so she was fun to talk trash apparently she's an
underdog i didn't even know that but uh this
is going to be this is going to be awesome here
and the game should be beginning shortly so you
know you know charlie better than anyone here
at thechest.com streaming community how
how uh how pumped is he to be back here
uh in pogchamps and and uh what what chances you
give him to maybe be one of the better players
he's definitely pumped that i know he's also
definitely nervous and i always point this out
these uh stars these streamers they are used to
broadcasting to millions and millions of people
danny but there's something about sitting
behind a chessboard be it a virtual chess
board or a real chess board that brings out all
the anxiety and i actually really like that so
charlie he's experienced he knows what this
is like at the same time uh we're gonna watch
his time consumption and uh i don't know too much
about code muco but i think she's put in the work
well right now she started out pretty pretty
well she played some natural developing moves
right i mean this is um not the most traditional
approach against a sicilian and charlie handles
it like a pro with e6 and d5 but but there's
some risk in an opening like this if if miko can
can play aggressively in the center early
on maybe she'll maybe she'll be okay here
yeah for sure she needs to strike in the center
d4 uh get her pieces out quickly rookie wants she
goes d3 she's doing everything right preparing the
development of her dark square bishop and charlie
quickly focusing on getting that king to safety
uh by castling yeah bishop v7 supernatural move
but this is this is a great start i mean even
though we were saying d4 i actually kind of
liked that she played d3 because it protects
against c4 maybe maybe she she would have got
her bishop trap so this is some really awesome
principal chess she's bringing out her pieces and
all right now i'm nervous i'm excited i'm excited
too this is great and they're both getting their
pieces out doing everything right mikko brings
her last piece out charlie still has that dark
light squared bishop to bring out uh which he
can put on a bunch of different squares and um
they are following the fundamentals to the letter
name yeah and you know something about the way
she's playing two just the tempo of it right
even if this is the most traditional approach
against charlie sicilian she's playing all these
developing moves with confidence if you look at
the fact that she has nine and a half minutes
so i'm gonna do the early kind of hecarim call
to action and just say i kind of think she's
underrated at 333 he tends to kind of look at
the ratings and see how they play and i i would
say now that she's probably underrated at 300.
she absolutely is and i completely agree with
you just by these first moves uh she's showing
complete command of the fundamentals
and uh you don't do that you know if
you're if you've had one chest listen so she's
definitely been putting in the work now charlie
um i'm gonna be straight up with you danny
he he has a big weakness in terms of his time
consumption when he's playing casually uh he he
plays confidently but when he's on the big stage
sometimes he freezes so we'll see whether he
can uh he can control that here in this game
we're going to throw to him right now for the
first time today and see what charlie's thinking
about we're not thinking
i'm not gonna do anything too crazy here
he's illuminating even his thoughts here tanya
so deep you can't express them
wow he's not usually this silent you're telling me
uh like you said you you know him well and he's
nervous um he's obviously gonna like to trap
this bishop see what he's considering by by
what he's doing with the pieces and where
he's moving his mouse um but uh but i think
she's going to want to take to double my pawns
yeah he's that's some pretty
high level thinking he sees that
miko probably wants to take that knight
i don't remember if we care about double pawns
in this line or not that's also high level
thinking right there because it is recognizing
it and then using i'm taking too long already
right i'm just going to say we don't
care about double pawns and go for it
what's going on did that just happen
let's let's come back here to the main board
and i you played bishop f4 in point one i'm
pretty sure she had accidentally clicked it
for a pre-move or she or she was pre-moving
which would be you know kind of a surprise kind
of uh you know high-level play there for her to
pre-move and and maybe not a very smart one
with with charlie playing b5 but let's throw
to code mikko now for the first time and see
what she's thinking about it's okay it's fine
oh my god here he comes here
comes the pummeling guys
um the pummeling i have not been
looking forward to but kinda yes
oh jesus that's scary
all right well i guess we'll
have oh jesus that's not good um
um you know what you know what
guys you know what i'm just spence
i'm just gonna go here
not a great move
okay more than six news okay probably does it
all right
that's what she's missed
shut up okay
she's playing so fast that's that's the
thing that i would advise her yep oh
shut up shut up everyone oh
wait what oh i didn't even
oh i didn't even say hey you know what guys you
know what we we did it was more than six moves
that's that's for sure um she did good that by
her saying that makes me feel like she just kind
of knew she was the underdog but the truth
is her position she was doing well if maybe
she just slowed down a little bit right i think
it started here with her pre-moving bishop f4
and then obviously the wheels kind of
come off pretty quickly from there so
i think that sometimes the players come in done
and they're just a little maybe a little psyched
out and that that definitely feels like one
of those which is unfortunate because i think
i think she showed some things that were
better than where this game ended so quickly
absolutely her development was on point she
showed an ability to see where the pieces belong
and she responded to threats when charlie
attacked one of her pieces she moved it back
but i completely agree with you i think the issue
was that pre-move and as you said the wheels
came up when you blunder a piece it can be so
disheartening and even subconsciously you can sort
of lose lose your ability to approach the position
objectively but still definitely impressive stuff
in the opening yeah i agree and um obviously
we're always surprised and not surprised with
dog champs games and things that happen sometimes
but i think that where this game started dylan i'm
surprised it ended the way it did that's what i'm
that's what i'm gonna say do you do you agree with
that completely agree and i think uh on move
11 she probably should have followed through
with uh capturing charlie's knight just so that
her bishop doesn't get trapped and uh right i
think you know sometimes these players just a
little bit of confidence is lacking and following
through on their ideas but by and large uh you
know she's gonna hold her head up high yeah no
i agree and you're right so right here she played
bishop a4 as charlie was saying we were listening
in maybe she wants to take my knight and double
the pawns but and then she kind of left that plan
behind and we see the eval bar reveal exactly how
the computer feels about that d5 and uh you know
at this point while bishop four was a premium as
you're saying the bishop is already trapped and
so the game was in theory you know grand master
level chess black is already winning and but but
i think that it's less about that i think it was
more indicative like right here i think sometimes
one of the things that we learn as you get better
at chess like when a player attacks you don't
always have to meet fire with fire right so so a
retreating move is sometimes in order but but it
feels like no no that then that means i'm losing
right but then by definition you play the really
aggressive move and lose and and that's kind of
kind of what happened here because the wheels
came off super quickly and got up to charlie
though i mean i guess obviously he's doing what
he came to do getting some dubs and uh pogchamps
three presented by grip6 and uh and here we go man
what do you think your students feel right now
what would you be advising him to stay focused
yeah definitely he's got to stay focused keep
the foot on the gas pedal it's a two game match
and uh it can be devastating to lose
the second game after winning the first
uh so you know he's got to reward him reorient
himself and there were points in this first game
where i think he took a little bit too much time
so he can quickly go over that and sort of figure
out where he could have played a little bit
faster but right he's got to refocus and uh
you know still you've got to take your time it's
very important not to make any sloppy pre-moves
but you sound like a coach she's almost just
hoping he's watching you right now but okay so
speaking of the fact that there is a next game
there's actually a lot of games still coming up
here in pogchamps so uh if you haven't already
grab your grab your phone right now everyone's
got some sort of google calendar sync these
days and type it in and you know you cancel
the dentist appointment and you and you add
oh yeah i gotta be here i gotta be here uh
on wednesday the 17th for xqc taking on poking
me so uh there's the schedule at least for the
dentist sorry say that say it again what's that
what's a dentist yeah appointment what is it
yeah who needs who needs teeth right oral hygiene
a duck right okay here we go that was weird it was
february 18th we've got uh only two matchups but
they are big ones we've got michelle care versus
logic then we've got rain versus tubbo um and the
games the games continue right there before you
the bracket stage uh or sorry the group stage
comes to an end on the 21st and we will have
our first rest day a break day for us to kind
of work with all the players and the streamers
and their busy schedules and and make sure that
things are lined up for the bracket stage to begin
on february 23rd and on that note this will be
how it looks right you have the players put into
seedings accordingly based on how they perform
here in the groups and we play until we have a
pog champs winner pog champs three presented by
grip six now the winner's gonna get a belt can
i like show the belt right now that against our
sponsor we got to see it you i mean am i allowed
to i'm asking for i do things all the time to get
us in trouble and then get dms and say no dan dan
you weren't supposed to do that there it is baby
oh man yeah it's sweet that is awesome it's good
it's it's not just a trunk it's titanium enough
to hold up a fat guy's pants and then you just
right there so whoever gets this i think that
i think that they will be streaming with it
behind them for the rest of their streaming
career the podcamp's belt is pretty awesome
it is you can't just leave that anywhere it
has to occupy the central place uh in this game
that's awesome danny i like it it's not just a
trophy it's creative it's not just a trophy right
it's a belt why don't more chess turners have
belt right i mean ufc's been doing it you know
heavyweight wrestling i miss hulk hogan i miss you
hulk hogan okay moving on to the bots let's remind
you you can play bots uh whether you're into
playing v tubers or um people who claim to be
bots that they could never be like ludwig go beat
ludwig's bot in fact if anyone beats ludwig's bot
and tweets it at me with like a funny phrase
i'm gonna choose one today and just give away
a one-year diamond membership because it makes
ludwig's day bad and makes me happy it's a win-win
makes the moment i heard makes you happy
i was gonna do it but you know danny you
disawaited me from it why'd you have to
say that jokes aside jokes aside we're
gonna take our first break of the day when
we come back it's game two code miko versus
moist critical don't go anywhere pog champs
three presented by grip six when we return
burger tier list win i'm trying not to do too
many food tier lists i'm doing a lot of food
how many games have you won in chess
in total i don't know man i've played
so so so many games of chess i have
no [ __ ] idea i have no goddamn clue
still miko we play we play more
makes the prime kevin in the prime x
we're doing a baby food tier list i think
that's the next one but i'm trying not to
do too many food ones i really wanted
to do the edible [ __ ] tier list but
the only one that was up to up for it was pay
money wobby so i mean i can't just like tier
list one [ __ ] i need more resub just joe in the
prime ayman you're live on chess like right now
like they heard my okay if we're live on chess
right now don't steal my edible [ __ ] to your
list please i'm still trying to get more
people for it i saw ludwig say he'll do it
i just need like six or seven people of my friends
not random people because i already know they're
just gonna send me like dirty [ __ ] mold
makes the two gift subs sensei
in the prime juice box and the resub salad hey
to tie it back into chess yeah i could try a
bunch of grand masters chocolate buttholes
it's a it's a company that does them so you
mold you mold your [ __ ] with some alginate
you send it in they turn it into chocolate and
i can just try different buttholes and
see which grandmasters taste the best
it could be a whole chess.com event you've
seen the grand masters but how do they taste
thanks theresa meyers in the
gift sub pog in the prime as raj
think positive you got this ah yes positive
thinking can achieve the impossibles
be positive
are we positive thinkers are we positive
dreamers do we dream or do we meme
we do both when we dream a meme at the same
time there's nothing we cannot do we can achieve
everything
we are clock positive
together
damn when is when is it gonna start
ah we still have a few minutes let's go baby
let's go six move uh more than six move let's go
let's do it let's do it
let's do it let's do it hey
and we are back pogchamps 3 presented by grip
6. you heard it you heard it from code miko if
you dream and meme anything is possible
dreaming and memeing together is a win
absolutely it's a two-game match she's pumping
herself up we saw some signs of mastery in game
one so uh this match is far from over all right
well the games are going to begin any second
we'll see what uh what code miko does with
the black pieces obviously charlie will have
white i like that dream and meme i'm gonna
i'm gonna steal that one for later um but
uh anyway thanks for being with us no matter where
you're tuning in from here we go it's gonna be an
awesome day we got mystery ludwig up ahead we
got crazy stuff charlie plays e4 here we go
and an e5 from code miko and the vienna gambit
is what charlie has been playing over the last
couple of weeks that's where white goes f4 pretty
quickly but here he develops his bishop yeah this
is a really aggressive line right obviously when
you play f4 at some point the f-file will lead
the rook and bishop having a date right there
on f7 or at least they hope to and the pressure
becomes very very very very strong very quickly
depending on whether black knows what to do
so uh miko already given it a think right here
right it's not the most common opening which
is part of the reason that uh it's very effective
because if you can get your opponent out of their
comfort zone pretty early and you know the
ideas you get a pretty big edge on the clock and
often that translates into an
advantage over the board right
well now already white has the option to play f4
and you can also play d3 if you still want to sort
of slow jam the idea um of course you always have
the option of going back into a more traditional
kind of whatever that would be two nights four
nights but no as we already we already know
because uh because we have the profit here f4 is
charlie's weapon what do you think is going to
happen at some point in the event when he plays
against someone who's prepared for his vienna
how's that gonna go well he's gonna have to
tighten up the screws the thing with these
openings right if they work out for you you can
score some quick victories if you mess up the move
order you mess up one move it's a double-sided
sword and you can get in trouble pretty darn fast
but uh so far charlie's showing nice command of
the principles getting rid of the pin immediately
yeah and the risk as you said because if it goes
wrong what you've done is open up a lot of dark
squares but okay here we see an example of how
it goes right a lot a lot of times people don't
really realize how aggressive this line can
be and just like that your bishop is trapped
yeah komiko bishop trapped on one side
of the board and now it's trapped on the
other side of the board in the other game
and she does the right thing giving it up
for a pawn if you're losing a piece you
want to give it up for as much as possible
yeah she takes it that's a good move and i
and i again i think the only thing i would say
is obviously it's hard you know when you when
you feel like you're playing a stronger player
but i think that she may be like we said in
game one thinks she's a little worse than she is
and and is playing kind of too fast if she if
she slows down a little bit you know um because
the openings she's had are very principled
right she's gotten pieces out she understands
all of those all of those development kind of
ideas and we'll see if she gets castle here
it's the king out of the center yeah she's she's
developing all her pieces and you can't say it
enough it's not that easy to get into a situation
where you have commanded the principles and that's
exactly what she has uh maybe again maybe taking
a little bit more time would have been good
but these unconventional positions they can be
hard to get your footing in but other than that
you know you could confuse or play for
that of magnus or maybe gary caspara
yeah i mean what would gary
kasparov think about this position
well if only we had him on the show but danny tim
this reminds me of the match against uh another
court company and uh in that match you know it
was uh back and forth you know looking for the
game but him go to mikko now she she knows um how
to develop her pieces you know but like a good
russian school boy do you think do you think
good russian school boys gary was a busy man
would good russian school boys appreciate
the v tuber experience you think gary
you know where i come from you know it's um
the v2 marine is i'm old school you know i like
uh flip phones you know notebooks you know button
i can definitely appreciate you know the sort of
the rise you know the ai and you know i've spoken
about it you know in colleges in it before but um
overall you know i'm quite approving of you know
the strength okay there you go thank you gary
um we'll uh maybe check in with you a little
bit later all right look at this move knight
h5 from her when mikko puts that on h5 it opens
up the check and we see charlie make his first
kind of odd move of the day let's listen into
code miko and see if she sees the check and
what she can do here drawing is important but
that's gonna get that guy so then you uh no i
wanna i wanna get rid of some of my some of my
pieces are so stuck uh that night on age five
exactly wanted to do anything
oh [ __ ] i know what he's
trying to do he's trying to
okay okay okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait i get what he's trying to do all right
wait why can't i do this um i'm confused
um don't worry don't don't panic
don't panic everybody don't panic
okay don't panic just don't panic
nobody panic it's okay nobody panic
i'm not either uh
nobody we're not panicking i don't understand
why i can't move this but um nobody panics stop
penegate okay stop yelling danny why are
you panicking danny why are you panicking
okay queen d7 and backing up a couple
moves it actually is unfortunate that
she just didn't realize knight h2 was played
quickly by charlie but probably a little too
quickly because he you know if she had
played the move bishop h4 check right
right and that would have forced the king to move
and when the king has to move this early danny
it can land in some danger yeah there's
uh there's knight g3 coming there's all
kinds of stuff happening so um okay she
played 95 as we saw instead and uh lost
the knight and now we'll see if charlie
can see how dangerous the g file is the
uh computer is actually announcing mate
and six but let's see what charlie sees
yeah and what you can see here white is
up two pieces and there's also this g
file white's got a rook positioned and facing
right at black's king and that pawn that is
covering the king is very flimsy you can attack
that pawn with a variety of pieces you can
bring your bishop out all the way to h6 and the
pawn you could just choose bishop because it is
yeah the he's not he's not talking i
don't know how best to approach this mate
this is something i also need to work on i
see a lot of different mating options here
i see a [ __ ] ton of mating options i just don't
know like the best and fastest way of doing it
i mean like i could literally drop
queen back i could push queen up
because this is pinned she cannot take i'm
just gonna push it up that's the best move
that's the fastest mate got
it easy he's hesitating though
and he's d he's done it
queen is untouchable because
of the thing to me that looks
okay if she comes here i can just take the bishop
if she pushes this up i do the original plan
seeing things very clearly yeah that's
impressive that's an impression using the pen
he's nervous he's worried there's a defensive
resource somewhere but there isn't any
do i want to just take that with
any of the three pieces actually
doing her best block the g file
but unfortunately it's just
hold the pin oh yep now
it's and now it's made on g7
and there it is
wow that was a commanding attack there by
charlie i had a lot of different options there
i had a [ __ ] ton of options i just didn't
know how to best approach it in the fastest way
i feel like i had a faster option
i just don't know what it was
he actually actually didn't he actually
didn't have a faster option so um
real talk he was he was awesome um i mean we can
we can go through it real quick the computer was
first pointing i mean really knight h2 was um was
less than ideal of a move right if if uh black is
still down a piece but if miko had seen bishop
h4 check the game could have been very different
right um one thing you one thing you noted is that
um again players as they as they gain experience
sometimes are just looking after you do the basics
of development like what's a one move thread
i could play so she she was feeling cramped
and was kind of looking for her next threat
but they but they don't always see the threat
for their opponent coming right and that's
that's where this backfired and right here
after queen d7 it's already a forced mate
was there anything fancier he could have
done besides queen h6 i don't think so
i don't think so either you could have
sacrificed the rook on g7 but that was
counterproductive because you want to keep
the rook it's the main attacker you could
have also brought the bishop to h6 but queen h6
was both the most elegant move and the fastest
checkmate and that's an area where charlie
has improved tremendously danny that area he
was unsure but his intuition indicated the best
and fastest way to make yep well rook takes g5
and uh this is this is this was already already
over and so so ali ali i guess uh ouch town
yeah i mean as i said mikko's going to hold her
head up high she's doing a lot of things right
and she's going to keep improving yeah and i think
that again sometimes in the in the early the early
rounds right you're you're kind of everyone is
sort of figuring out the strength of the players
and i think that uh mikko if and when she hooks up
with her coaches will be told like hey you weren't
doing bad you got all your pieces developed
right just focus on a little more emphasis
on your opponent's threats and slow down just a
little bit right i think that that would probably
be the advice we would want to give her and i'm
being given uh and told the cue that it's time
for us to take a break before we are joined by
our players for an interview so don't go anywhere
interviews with moist critical and code miko
when pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6 returns
three would mean a lot if you checked it out
i'll check it out bud you get 3 000 if you get
dead last thank you polite for the host brother 3k
if you get dead last if you lose every single game
for about maybe three hours of your time two hours
of your time thousand dollars an hour that's not
bad that's not bad 1k an hour that pays for like
one of code miko's cogs all right what do we got
oh [ __ ] it's on me hey uh what's up uh um i
don't know you guys don't have a name what's
up chess.com uh are you guys wondering why watch
uh why would one player wanna play game when they
get [ __ ] on we make three thousand dollars if we
lose every game it's one thousand dollars an hour
to be a loser it's the greatest deal of all time
i don't think that you get a lot of money when
you lose most of the time i don't know somebody
asked the new york jets i'm not aware perhaps
the knicks might have more information on this
fact all i'm saying is that's a pretty sweet deal
anyway if you guys don't know um chess.com
that is uh check this out mr beast tweeted
at me this afternoon and he said hope
you don't mind me taking your king today
and then in a spout of courage in stupidity i
tweeted i'll give you ten thousand if you do
thinking that he would be like yeah
you know cause it's mr beast you'd
be like yeah let's put 10k on it
thinking i could get like a free 10k
and then he just followed up and
said um i'll take it in bitcoin um
so he didn't really
hold up his end of the bargain
there i thought that was gonna be
i thought it was gonna be like you know
yeah let's do it 10k grudge match
i don't even know what it means he said
takes your king does that mean beats me
in the whole set or if he wins one game do i do
i give 10k if he wins two games do i lose 20k
we don't know the specifics stressed out man
i'm stressed out we'll be fine we'll be fine
dream is streaming react and get free clout genius
what the [ __ ] and then on top of that
dude [ __ ] twitch on god i hate this [ __ ]
website i started streaming like three years ago
and i wanted to be the biggest streamer and back
in the day it was like soda pop and he had like
25k he hit like 70k once with an unboxing he was
like the biggest stream ever now [ __ ] tommy and
it's dumbass gets like 100k natty doing whatever
the [ __ ] i'm out here starving trying to get 20k
viewers doing whatever i can putting up 10k for
diddly squat 53k on shroud for crumbs crumbs what
happened to twitch bro it used to be so easy how
am i supposed to get the biggest on twitch it's
impossible i don't know i don't know i hate
it i hate it i hate it here what is the point
i'm your crumb thanks thanks for the crumb
of couch chat i appreciate it but god damn
has my dream died with dream smp being the
actual murder ironic dream killed my dream
anyway um if you guys could all consider starting
i think the best way to grow is for everybody to
live tweet my stream so if you guys could hop
on twitter um oh my god can't believe ludwig
uh said that and then you have to like basically
click bait people who follow you to be like what
they say okay you guys are just saying no all
right i'm just gonna run three minutes of ads
well they did a countdown on
chess.com i was hoping it would leave
and we are now joined by mikko and charlie after
this first match on day three of pogchamps uh
great games great games guys uh mikko we i wanted
to look at the chess because we were listening in
on you during during some of the games and there
were some moments where it felt like maybe you
thought your position was worse than it was and
maybe we could look at some of this and and go
over some tips for the future if that's okay
yes please okay cool so in this position here
you actually had a great opening to start you
developed all your pieces and got castled and
even charlie was recognizing when you played
bishop a4 that maybe you had a plan to double
his pawns and then right here it it felt like you
started playing really fast on the clock your next
couple moves were with the bishop on this side of
the board and that's where obviously we can see
how the computer feels about it that's where it
kind of started to go haywire and and you got your
bishop trap so take us through what your thought
process was once you got your pieces developed
and what are you thinking about for future games
um well i i accidentally misclicked and i did a
pre-move and i didn't know that was a thing uh i'm
just knuckles that's what i hypothesized as well
there's no way that's code miko she's too smart
for that yeah well not i'm not exactly i mean
but yeah i misclicked and then i also accidentally
hit the back button so i almost left the game too
oh got it yeah that's what we were thinking as
well okay so um yeah that's awesome news because
that's what we were we wanted we wanted to go over
it and give advice because your position was great
um did you think about when you played bishop
a4 were you thinking about taking the night here
yep of course i was uh-huh yeah that would have
been a good idea to double charlie's funds and
then your bishop wouldn't have landed
in as much trouble yeah perhaps you
could have attacked that pawn by shifting
your knight over to the center right yeah
the uh the this this game this game ended up
um you know like i said it started out really
well and even this one here there was a position
right here charlie i don't know if you know when
you played knight h2 which obviously had this
threat if miko had played bishop h4 check this
could have got a little spicy charlie did you did
you see this idea coming uh that's definitely not
where i wanted to put the knight i just didn't
know the right square for it and i was trying
not to overthink it yeah i definitely didn't
see that though wait i have a free night grab
not so much that but more that you could have
uh weakened white's king because when you give
a check this early forces the king out into
the open yeah and then you can follow up by
shifting your knight into g3 with another check
and it's not terrible for white but it creates uh
some you know some unbalanced uh situation here
oh my god i'm learning so much well and it felt
like maybe maybe the takeaway too is is obviously
you did a great job in both openings getting all
the pieces out getting the king safe and then it
felt like maybe you were you were looking for a
plan and one of the best ways to look for a plan
is trying to improve the the less active pieces
the the worst pieces so like maybe here looking
for an opportunity to improve the queen and bishop
staying on this side of the board where you had
played the last move sometimes the easiest way
to have a good plan is to stack moves on the
same side of the board like rather than sort of
what happened where you where you played moves
on different sides of the board back to back
it kind of leads to a disjointed plan
whereas if you if you try to build up
pieces on the same side of the board your
army's working together and so rather than
just the specific bishop h4 tip maybe that's
a tip for future games right look to move all
your pieces on one side of the board a little more
coordinated oh that's awesome i didn't know that
i'm super apologetic it wasn't what we
played but we just wanted to go over
the games because you guys you guys uh gave
us a treat and charlie obviously you played
super well so obviously the serious question
has to come just how long is your hair now
oh i i haven't measured it but it's got to be
pushing like uh one or two feet right like it's
probably a good percentage of my overall height
at this point since i have the height of like a
child like we've got to be getting pretty close
to that threshold well as your rating grows so
does your hair ain't that the truth yeah i
get more powerful yeah so charlie just one
quick question for you do you feel uh similar
to how you did in pogchamps one do you feel
like that experience is making you less nervous
or is it uh the sort of same kind of sensation
oh absolutely not i think it's a lot more nerves
this time because i won the the losers bracket
the consolation participation trophy bracket and
now i'm like almost expected to win some games
and i think that sucks that [ __ ] is tough man
having to play with like an expectation to do well
yeah definitely can relate i've been playing with
low expectations on me for years so you can come
back my way whenever you're ready low expectations
um mikko what about you start taking the games
nico this is your first blog champs event
get out from me how are you feeling yes
oh i was really really excited
i'm super nervous to go against
like literally chest jesus himself um but i was
just really happy that i did more than six moves
yeah no i think that's great that was one of
the finest performances i've seen in pogchamps
typically i'm slapping cheeks around six moves
you went all the way to like 12 in some cases
yay that's why i was saying go more if we just
do more than six moves we're winning for me today
amen exactly well we'll be looking for you to
improve um that was very well played both of you
you guys were nice thanks for showing the tips
i think uh i'll use that for my next tournament
yeah well obviously you've got board members and
what are your thoughts over the next couple weeks
you're gonna have you're gonna have two more
matches in the group and then either the
championship or consolation bracket are you are
you looking to get some some coaching and crush
some peeps from here or you just you're
just kind of here for the experience
my group d is very very very fun um
ludwig is gonna be fun to play against
i played against his bot and he completely
crushed me um and then i'm really looking
forward to mr beast because i've heard from my
chat that mr beast is like my level so that's
going to be fun um i'm going to get some more
coaching and um and just have more fun i think
charlie have you beaten it's the wrong
mentality miko there's no fun here
no no no no brutalize people miko yeah
i will work day and night to brutalize ludwig next
week or that should be easy his bot is so much
better than him anyway like when you play real
ludwig it's going to be night and day yeah really
oh yeah he cannot play even like his bot wait
seriously no okay i honestly think he just uses
the chat when he plays games and just takes their
moves i've never seen him have an original thought
wow ah them fighting words thanks moist for
giving me courage i'll tell my child to put all
in on me next time oh absolutely that's a safe bet
uh you guys have been great uh charlie again
congrats and starting your your pogchamps return
got pressure on yourself this time but
you're also you you've gotten so much
better man over the last few months it's been
awesome to watch your crush in it and mikko
these were good games good start to the
event and best of luck in in the next round
thank you so much guys thanks for having me
thank you thank you great games all right
well that was that was fun and you know i
definitely agree with charlie about ludwig's chess
experience and strength for her oh absolutely
yeah i mean i think i've lost the live wig spot
before and i actually haven't but i'm pretty
sure i will but charlie and ludwig will play
i wonder i would pay to just see charlie bot
play against ludwigbot on chess.com with the
two of them comment commenting over it and just
uh just commentating over their bot battling
against each other could be great uh remind
chad if you upload the first one to upload a
video of you beating lovely bot today gonna
get a diamond membership for me on twitter
while you're while you're waiting for the next
match go ahead and throw me throw me a video
if you beat lovebookbot on twitter so anyway
this is this is already a lot of fun we've got
lud coming up versus mr beast if you missed it
uh more is on the line in this matchup between
love wig and mr beast then then even the
the pog champs money so don't go anywhere
we'll remind you of what what banter's been
going on on social media when we come right back
boyfriend applications for v2 or mika
and it's going to turn into a game show
it's gonna be it's gonna first start with me and
reviewing your boyfriend applications for vtuber
then we're gonna move on to a job a
hiring it's gonna be like the office
where i will interview these boyfriends
like they do in the office and then it's gonna
turn into a full-on game show full-on competitive
game show so guys wait i'm on chess tv wait
what what do you mean what do you mean i'm
still in just tv i shouldn't be i shouldn't
be on chess tv i should be stop trolling me
anyways i love you guys
let's go
rest up i'm gonna go rest up and
the 27th is my birthday everybody
we're having an incredible stream
we're not trolling off freaking hell i mean guys
hello chess tv um i did not know i was on chess tv
i'm sorry for um if i said anything that was not
just i love you all thanks so much for having me
on chess tv um yeah i love i love everybody there
yeah i understand i'm on chess tv i understand
okay you you've told me that already i i get
it now i'm good i'm good anyway i love you guys
um 27th is my birthday we have we are we're gonna
we're having a technician stream but we're having
a technician stream like no other has seen
on stream before we're gonna have the most
we're gonna do something that no twist
stream has ever done before on twitch so
come for my birthday stream that is on
the 27th i'm going to set up a p.o box
and one of the things that we're gonna do is
open up presents that you guys have sent me
on the po box and um yeah guys
if you have not already uh
join my patreon so and if you have joined
my patreon make sure you write your username
on my patreon on the post you will see it
because we will start shouting out patreon names
um what else do i have anything else um
dr k is tomorrow tomorrow is technician
stream and we are going to be on dr k tomorrow
i will be there will be tears um and we're
going to be talking about i think i'm going
to change the topic to my workaholic uh
situation and how i feel guilty about
spending time with my friends or things like that
um there's gonna be tears um and then after that
we're gonna go on cash up trivia then after that
oh i have to plan out oh okay this saturday and
sunday is gonna be interesting i have to lock
down times and dates but um this this weekend
might get really interesting okay everybody i
love you guys um i will uh talk to you guys later
and um i'll i'll see you guys on my discord i love
you all thank you so much for joining this chess
stream today with me let's go lightweight
i'll promise i'll try to spend some time
practicing more chess i love you guys bye join
my youtube subscribe to your youtube channel
and before our next match takes off we
are now joined by mr beast himself one
of the biggest youtubers in the world and
jimmy i gotta ask before the match starts
what charity will you donate ludwig's ten
thousand dollars to after you beat him today
oh i have to donate it to charity
uh no you don't know absolutely
i know i'm kidding i'm kidding uh i feel bad just
stealing 10 grand from him wait am i moving out
of cam it's really zoomed in you're a little
crowded we're going to fix it right now here
we go okay good yeah uh saint judes why not cancer
sucks cool that's awesome i uh i i we were joking
off camera that you'll maybe have you have a lot
of people rooting for you today and obviously we
love ludwig so we like to tease him he's streaming
right now but what how are you feeling about today
right you're making your pog champs debut you've
had some chess sessions some coaching under your
belt and what are your what are thoughts what
thoughts are going through your head right now
um well i i have a game plan um i i i mean ask
me afterwards i feel more in depth but i i do
have a game plan we'll see if it falls apart
um yeah we'll we'll just put it there okay
he does the same opening basically every
game he just yeah he's a one-trick pony
yeah completely whether i'm smart
enough or not to take advantage of that
we'll find out today well he spreads all these
rumors about his own strength how do you feel
about that his bot um he's created his whole
cult of personality are you buying any of that
uh yeah no he's pretty good i was i've been
watching a few of his streams uh he he knows what
he's doing i think he'll be pretty competitive
um i'm just gonna do my best not to blunder
anything and like just completely screw up that
way uh but i i think it will be a pretty good game
speak of the devil i think we have some is that
the man did he join well um jokes aside this is
awesome of course we wish you the best of luck and
before we let you go let me just say again that
um as when we when we invited you to the
event and you were on board what was uh
what was the biggest factor was it the charitable
element you want to get involved we know your
stream does awesome things in that way or were
you just like everyone else fell in love with
the queen's gambit and beth harmon and wanted
to give wanted to give chess your best chance
i i played chess a lot when i was
younger but i i stopped playing and then
like everyone else i'm ashamed to admit i
watched queen's gambit i got back into it
uh honestly it just seemed like something fun
you know what i mean to take my my mind off of
working and so i've enjoyed practicing a little
bit and i'm excited well regardless of how the
match goes we hope that's the interesting one
it continues on social media showing everybody
the tweet right now you guys have had some fun
going back and forth so our you know i know it's
all in fun and just my gosh oh there's the man
oh my god i thought we were about to end uh-oh
okay first of all um can i call you can i call you
mister instead of mr beast oh sure whatever you
want whatever you want these chess.com clowns
okay and let's just call them what they are
feeding content hit me in the dms they go hey
do you want to hop on to talk [ __ ] on mr beast
bigger man i said no no this guy look he's a
little bit nervous like come on busy man i don't
want to do this to him come to find out you're
on here talking [ __ ] calling me one trick pony
all right at one point what is this what is
this mister i thought we had a thing going on
i thought this was like a there's a friendly
mouth what i didn't call you one trick pony
they called you one i did it and you didn't
call danny dumb and stupid for it but she
is i mean to be fair yeah we'll see okay
what so so like out of curiosity like
what's your real rating because like your
account you don't play a lot of games on
500 uh somewhere probably between 500 and 600
i don't know wait is it actually you're baiting
you're i don't want to give away too
much i thought you were busy this was
supposed to be my freebie match i thought
you had like [ __ ] work to do or something
17 youtube channels in like a food facility
have you been playing chess all of a sudden
we'll see i i don't want to give away too much the
more i tell you the more competitive advantage you
have jimmy this is the one match i wasn't supposed
to stress about i came in here it's a [ __ ] meme
i put up ten thousand dollars i was trying to
bait you to put another 10k up so i could get
easy clap 10k you didn't even fall for it i know
i noticed ah okay but you're right here i i i
will put up 10k though we're both throwing
on 10k winner what whoever wins not just
one gimbal whoever wins overall gets 10 grand
i'll match it wow sure yeah that's that's fine
i guess i if he says it i didn't say it that
was just me i like to make things more fun
yeah yeah though that would that
i that's that's crazy that would
help that's like 20 minutes of shroud's
time that's pretty good i'll take that
uh so well look i'm ready i played your bot and
let me tell you i i stunted on your bot like you
[ __ ] on it i [ __ ] on your bot i i checked your
body they purposely made them suck wait why debate
me what is this misdirection you're doing okay
that's fine i feel good about this you know what
we'll see what happens here i i bet i bet you move
uh your pond uh in front of your king first the e4
dude he's gonna psyche me out and this is maybe
his game plan he's gonna make me play some dumb
[ __ ] now i'm going to play a terrible opening
line because he's in my head this is like that
one time donya you'll remember when tall laughed
at world champion bobby fischer when he wrote
down a move he was going to do and then bobby
fischer decided to not play that move and tall
ended up winning the game yep but i still have
bobby fischer behind me but i do remember that's
historical knowledge i see yeah it's whatever
oh jesus did you not know about that jimmy it
was just a little bit of chess history i've been
brushing up on might not be um the most accessible
i read actually i read bobby fischer's
biography i i find him very interesting
i listened to the audiobook and i got bored
halfway through same but i kept powering through
because i was already halfway did you read it read
it or audiobook it audio uh yeah okay when i say
read i mean listen no one no i do too i do too
i just i would have felt really dumb if you were
also a book reader what i didn't think you had
time to do stuff i thought all you do is youtube
well you gotta turn your brain off occasionally
it's like ninety percent of my life is youtube
and the other ten percent i'm like struggling to
find something you got three youtube channels uh
like uh what do you call that a podcast all right
calm down we don't have you have a girlfriend
you got how do you okay i'm over it i'm over it
i'm over it all right we'll just see what happens
on the planet that's always a good community
always a good one to cut off right there because
i think that what we wish both of you guys best of
luck i know i speak for everyone when i say that
everyone will be rooting for you jimmy um so
danny on robo for anyone else is just me let's
go for it go for it guys you want a robo mo danny
robo but what you gotta fix your mic brother yeah
yep you want you want a robot as well all
right just has that effect on people i'm down
are we playing now or do we go yeah let's
go let's get the world waiting i'm gonna go
we'll see you on the other side as the players get
ready i want to give one more shout out of course
to grip six not only are they sponsoring pogchamps
and you saw the belt earlier we also have this
incredibly awesome custom made chess set they're
built as the only belt with no holes no flap no
bulk made right here in the u.s of a go to go to
go.chess.com grip6 to enter into the pot champs
ultimate giveaway and use the code pogchamps20
or 20 off all of grip six products they're
they're awesome i'm literally wearing their socks
right now i've really fallen in love with their
socks there's nothing against the belt or the
wallet but i i'm a sucker for some comfy feet
and so i'm wearing them um and uh on that note
another thing another reason to enter is you may
win that awesome custom chess set i've seen it
it's here in the office we'll be setting up at
some point so dania don't go anywhere that
interview was awesome i'm even more pumped
for ludwig versus mr beast we'll be right back
something's really off yeah we can't hear you
it's not on mine right like you guys
say the same thing is it on the show
but zoom it's not on the show no it's
not on the show it's just the zoom
yeah zoom does that every once a
while remember we had that before
donya is it still acting up
yeah it's like chops
yo
mr b 6 000 all right time to get hyped i'm a
little nervous now i didn't i didn't think he
i knew his account and i looked at it and he
only played like 20 games but now i know he
has a secret account that's way higher
rated and he also studied my openings
and so my 10 000 easy clap w might
become another financial disaster
but the prediction is live gamblers on my
channel so lay down the points if you believe
because i'm gonna try to roll this [ __
] and smoke them take it down take the w
for all the [ __ ] on youtube
who don't have 50 million subs
and don't give to charity often which
i guess is most of us i don't know
he's like such a good guy so it's hard to
really be mad at him but eat [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay i'm good to go i'm good to go i'm prepped
i had the sickest mate i feel so good
because i had such a sick mate on his butt
but it was his butt i just have to make sure i
put chat in a good place that i can cheat from
uh that way if i'm in a tough
spot i can just look over
runches.com right now
kidding closing out of you right now just
a joke just a meme just a meme is all just
a fun little joke come on guys you know
me just a fun little meme amongst friends
oh actually this is banger
hey here's i have uh one piece of advice
for mr beast and chess my first pitch
why listen to me it's for you mr
beast i am a decently attractive dude
i play video game make million
and we are back here after what was
pretty awesome pregame interview there i mean
obviously ludwig almost took over the show as he
always does but i felt uh i feel even more pumped
for this ludwig beast battle than i was before
i am super pumped as well after
all that talk we gotta have some
epic games to follow it up danny yeah here
they come i'm uh i'm following lud skywalker
his chess.com username i mean when is he
gonna is he 12 i mean is he still naming
himself after star wars characters so
anyway we got lud coming up right now
well you know he studies tall games he i think
he's stuck in the past he's stuck in the 70s i
don't know if that's a bad thing or a good thing
um he uh yeah trying to throw some shade on beast
obviously we know they're kidding and they're
and they're good friends and it's a lot of fun
um and uh apparently now this game is gonna
work out even better than it could have been
for ludwig if he beats beast he's got 10k coming
back to him because uh jimmy ponied up there
that's i mean as if the trash talk wasn't enough
we needed higher stakes uh i think this is awesome
i think the nerfs whoever's nerves are gonna give
out first that's that's what's going to determine
this game yeah and for those of you who maybe
just tuned in and i don't think so a lot of you
have been here we got more than 70 000 on twitch
and a lot of other people everywhere else but um
budwig tweeted this morning that he would give 10k
to jimmy if he lost and jimmy just matched the bet
so we got 10k on the line going into their
pockets we know that ludwig needs the money
going broke over there uh jimmy not so much
but uh but yeah it's all right games are
beginning right now here we go and mr beast fog
champs three presented by grip six continues
and one e4 and mr beast is stumped he's taking his
time he's waving that's a very rare move by ludwig
okay scandinavian all right man this just i'm
gonna have to deal with john bartholomew all
over again the team scandy hi guys james
candy here we go hey guys this is john
all right we just play scandi here he's gotten
his filthy hands on mr beast's opening repertoire
he's playing fast too so who is the better part
of all of you impersonation me or you probably me
well you need to do more of it you can't just
say two words and then uh have me award you the
bartholomew medal so did you not john what do you
think about the scandy you've not seen my april
fools video hi guys i stopped by starbucks on the
way all right so really proud of this video and i
wanted to bring it to you guys because it's
about the hundred a game series and uh okay
that was it was decent danny you know i'll give
you a b minus which is in my in my book is a
pretty good grade all right but um you know i've
heard of better impersonations to be completely
honest you're you are the impersonation king so
i'll let i'll let it be um all right let's talk
a little bit about the scandy because if you again
if you're just tuning in uh jimmy said he's been
doing some prep i actually know that he was doing
some coaching earlier today before this i don't
know if i'm allowed to say which coach maybe i am
but he was doing some some training and he said he
didn't want to go into what he prepared he wanted
to save it so here he's busting out the scandy
and uh i don't know i think love might
be nervous let's let's listen into lud
and see what he's thinking about so that would
stop that as well uh instead he attacks this
uh which is defended at the moment but
certainly could be a tricky situation
in the future uh this was all for a castle so
castle i shall i also have this threat though
so i'm actually just gonna be a little
prophylactic here maybe even a bit cowardly
but i'm gonna play this move actually doesn't
really defend it though i actually regret this
a bit because if he plays it if he might see if
he sees it if he plays this and i take he wins
so i can't even it's not it's actually a fake move
fake but that's fine he's laying a lot of
pressure here typical scandy fashion he does
decide to castle queenside uh i am going to
push up this pawn now uh understanding that
this bishop needs to leave and
this blocks any threat here
making this pretty much useless
and then i'm gonna probably go for a
d2 with my bishop looking at the queen
perhaps with the move like i don't know knight
over here doesn't really matter i think he's
doing well describing his thought process let's go
so he's going to push again maybe that's the idea
he's walking us through all the launchers
again and it's pretty good logic
e5 though yeah that's not bad did have some prep
look at this scandy cause if he pushes again here
and i take i'm threatened wallace
uh but it is attacked twice so i'm fine as well
so i'm gonna go here sticking to the plan if he
pushes i can just take with my pawn it frees it
up to capture because my queen is no longer being
attacked by this rook wow castling is an idea i
definitely want to achieve at some point in my
lifetime
i don't know but i think jimmy was feeling good
we we we had him off camera before but he was
smiling when he played e5 and kind of rubbing
his hands so we'll try to listen into him when he
he starts talking but uh he
he feels or he he's emanating
emulating confidence here i think i'm good i'm
not worried no cares in the world let's do it okay
yeah he's just so happy i love it well
confidence yeah i know there isn't that
maybe he's nervous but what's he gonna do oh boy
have i have i blundered yet uh have i lost the
game nope there you have it taking some time
he's really thinking here look he's up on the
clock i might if you keep talking about it
oh that's a dangerous smoke though gotta move
your queen blood did say that he thought that
i think a lot of people have been unsure
about jimmy's strength right because he
hasn't played as much we haven't known where
he was at and so maybe that's why ludd felt
confident enough to throw the 10k on the
line but if jimmy plays some good moves
out of this opening he's definitely gotten an
advantage as black which is saying something
absolutely and his pieces are active now he's got
to move his queen that's the first step and let's
see how he manages to play now that he's probably
out of his preparation he's got like you said he's
got to make a couple logical moves here but ludwig
is he's not in a terrible shape but he's developed
pretty passively here yeah but you're right he he
he's not in terrible shape especially if if jimmy
makes a false step with the queen here god forbid
he goes full bow test gambit never go full botezz
ever that's what they tell you right put the queen
on a safe square like this and you should be okay
completely and white can
take black's knight but then
that pawn from g7 can just recapture
and then black can use that file
and put a rook there and attack white's king
because ludwig is probably going to castle
short at some point and it's going to be a
race of who gets to the opposing king first
jimmy is uh gone into his first real think of the
game so whether he was literally prepped before
94 which would be incredible or he just felt like
confident enough about the opening he's obviously
gonna gonna need to speed up from here because
he's going on two full minutes having thought here
yeah and you know what concerns me danny is
the amount of time that he's thinking because
uh if you identify the threat you maybe spend a
minute deciding where you put the queen but okay
and he centralized that's a
great move seriously fantastic um
i was highlighting queen b6 um but queen d5 might
have been even better honestly this is this is a
great move especially if like dania said everybody
if the play switches somehow to the king side
the queen will be so ideal here i mean you can
even play e4 right away but just to highlight
what might happen with the queen and rook working
together so that would be some coordination here
if if beast can can convert the middle game
advantage to a king side attack that leads me
astray absolutely and in the early going
the time consumption is what concerns me
from both sides all right they're already
closed i don't think we're wasting anything
obvious
now if he castles king side that's a
dub for us i got my book threatening
pretty sure i can sound like an idiot full
disclosure i don't know what i'm talking about
but i think he does i assume i
think he does mr mr beast is uh
playing like a beast so far let's
listen to ludwig see how nervous he is
yeah that music is so calming though if he
pushes though i think that's my main concern
if he pushes and i capture and then the queen
captures that gets a little bit monkas but i think
if he pushes i can just push as well maybe hmm
or i can just stand my ground it's not really a
threat even though there's three attackers because
the queen is in front of the rook so he would lose
a queen in this trade i don't know if opting to
castle is too bitch-made i could also do this move
if i go weakens the pawn defended he can't go
here can't go here can't take could go here
that would kind of help him though
no no pretty good game right
yeah but look at the clock with this move is that
i'm no longer defending this piece so if i go here
he could attack and it's only defended
once but i would just take i'm gonna
i don't know if i'll regret this i
really don't but i'm gonna go with
the castle because i'm wasting a lot of
time gonna try to play a little bit quicker
because you only get five seconds per move i think
the last block chance was fifteen ten maybe ten
ten maybe it's ten five it was ten five just.com
can i stop getting front requests from me hermano
so we'll miss you will he see the
way to get to white's king well
okay regardless of what happens here beast
has already impressed us right donya i mean
i mean this is this is a high-level game here
and i'm impressed not only with mr beast's
preparation but how he's followed that through he
centralized his queen fundamentals now this is the
pivotal moment danny i really think that the next
couple of moves are going to decide the game will
mr beast understand the area of the board that
he has to play on that is a king side he's got
to start attacking white's game he's got to do
it quickly both players now down to five minutes
yeah and and i think we've been focused on beast
uh you know maybe we know him a little bit less
than lud and all that stuff but ludwig also
gets a ton of credit i mean he came out here
obviously against a well-prepared opponent
kind of surprised him and his position is
is totally playable right and you see he was
even highlighting he he saw the drawback of
advancing the pawn to c4 he pointed out that
the d3 pawn would be weak which was like also
also fantastic so yeah i mean um but now okay
now now beast is getting down yeah he understands
yeah and that's now he's below five minutes
and ludwig understands the danger which is
a very important thing if you're playing over
confidently uh you're much more likely to make
a blunder but i'm really really not liking this
this time consumption and he's done look at him go
that is really impressive danny dude seriously
right he's playing all the natural moves so
shout out to whatever kind of secret training uh
jimmy's been getting on on the side because he's
clearly clearly an underdog here uh surprising
people he's he is under five minutes so if this
game continues with both them you know playing
the way they are we it may just come down to
time pressure anyway which is part of life right
we don't play games that have hours and hours on
the clock anymore at least not in these online
events so uh we'll see but rook v8 what a move
that's a great move it pins the pawn
we saw charlie do something similar in
obviously in a different position but the idea
was the same uh in the future you could slide your
bishop over to h3 and attack that pawn because
it's pin so ludwig tries to preempt that but
he does weaken his king side a little bit beast
could still get his bishop down at h3 that would
be a great move yeah but g3 was really good by lud
right i mean it's anticipating just to show that
if if you waited with some random movement bishop
h3 came in everybody it's even worse because
now when you push g3 the pawn is pinned right
you can't take you lose the rook so so blood
also this is this is some high quality chest here
this is awesome i mean one of the things i can say
we're only three days into
pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
but uh i think the chess has been overall
maybe some of the best we've ever had
for sure in the ratings danny and i i know you'll
second me on this they don't tell the whole story
you might look at the number and say he's a
beginner but beast is playing some really high
quality chess but this will go down to a time
screw but where 12 moves in and he's below four
minutes let's not forget they're not experienced
at blitz and bullets so um if either of them gets
down to a minute that just might decide the game
unfortunately yep oh yeah so nervous someone's
going to get 10 grand in their pocket and it's not
me but one of these guys is going to lose 10 grand
today whoa e4 e4 that's another fantastic move
opening up the center he's got the and london saw
that possibility but it's still a dangerous move
yep mm-hmm oh man c4 counter-attacking the queen
about to get spicy everybody buckle up yep
the queen is attacked he's got to move it
where does he move let's think from here just
back to b7 that's a big critical over here
so there's only real tiles here
to which maybe i could go here it's
not defended though oh it is that works
if he goes here i could go here he
could interpose but then i can take
protected
okay so interpose i just take oh no i can't
take cause the rook [ __ ] i don't even see that
[ __ ] well that's fine we'll wait for
his move before we worry about ours
the flag i still he interposes might take here
because i still win a rook that's still a win
i lose a bishop in a knight
for a knight in a rook so
that's not actually that big of a
deal i'm not winning a queen boohoo
honestly i don't even know if it's
that bad to go takes takes two minutes
that might even be good for him to be totally
honest queen sacrifice oh did i blunder what no
no you didn't we talked about
that um huh okay i'll do
this he panicked that way i'm attacking
if he goes here i take this exposing
oh man that's unfortunate but it's how
some of these games have gone when you see
players play really well and you think their
strength is better than it is and you might
you might see that there's prep helping them
and they're getting positions they kind of
they feel good about but then having the
experience to play those and choose the
right plan in the critical moment is another
thing right and here jimmy after playing like
a like an absolute boss like a beast if you
will he uh he goes full bow test never do it
yeah and you can see in his face and it's
just body language uh he was all smiles
he's feeling confident vibing and now you
can just see the sort of he's not outwardly
showing anything but you can just tell the
disappointment and uh we can all relate to
that i mean we can no matter what level we
are we can all relate to this feeling of
realizing that you had a good position but you
couldn't quite make anything of it yeah well it
should give him confidence right regardless of
what happens in the match um that was an awesome
start to the game and he was playing quickly a
fantastic middle game and i think uh you know it
ludwig did the right thing when he started kind of
getting aggressive he played c4 even if it wasn't
objectively the best he started attacking uh mr
beast and uh and that was the pressure he needed
so i i i don't think that ludder's gonna blow this
at this point he's he's improved so much as well
a lot like charlie from pogchamps one right i just
don't think that lobeck doesn't win this game now
and i'm particularly impressed danny to your point
about his improvement with his logic i mean he was
spelling it out for us yep uh he was thinking
some very high level thoughts he was calculating
variations not all of his moves were great uh but
he was putting a tremendous amount of thought into
them so he's uh he's definitely on the grind
and it's really impressive to see honestly
yeah for sure and uh i think one of
the most impressive things was that
was that uh ludwig played quickly enough
even though he was getting outplayed
so to speak right jimmy had a better opening
bloodwork was on his on his heels a little bit
but he played quickly enough that um that he
was always in the game right and i think that's
a huge sign in experience right i think players
as they as they play more understand you can't
solve every problem on every move so you have to
at least give yourself a chance on the clock and
and then now now not only is he
winning but he's way up on time
yes and ludwig just did something somewhat
unnecessary he took the bishop with his rook
giving up an exchange now it's understandable he's
trying to simplify right he's trying to get pieces
off the board and it's kind of working uh that
wasn't necessary but it doesn't ruin anything
right well beast grabs the pawn here oh that's
such a good move that's a beautiful move let's
listen in on lubwig and see if he actually saw the
pin that he's gonna made him if he takes the rook
king can't move oh wow he did so i actually
pinned his wow bishop to a mate oh my gosh
and then i'll just do a little doubled up file and
i'll still go for a big it's a killer wallop dude
i'm super impressed by ludwig i obviously i do as
much as i can to to bag on him on a regular basis
no you got to take your hat
check now he has to take i take with check
um i hmm i will form up this is flat out
not a battery i forget the name for this
uh we're very safe here using
correct gesture we can go either
here he's not actually attacking us so this
is pretty irrelevant we just check the rook
look at the confidence now
wow and now there is very little
threat for us to lose this game
um but we will try to since he wants to keep
going not that i think he should stop but
uh we'll go here he goes down if he
goes down one then i just take it
he doesn't do that which is
totally fine um i will however go
i don't have a pin at the
moment i will check this way
danny this is textbook technique
it's gigi but maybe he finds something
who is this impostor all
right game one win this is
oh my gosh this is just nastiness who is
this imposter and what i mean with ludwig
this is ludwig kasparov ludwig tall he was talking
about those world champions they'd be proud of him
right now unbelievable uh all right well obviously
we're gonna take a very quick break before game
two begins super impressive coming out of the
gate by mr beast but ludwig holds on and takes
game one can jimmy turn it around with the white
pieces find out it's game two when we return
and i don't think there's a way out of
this well i guess i can just go here right
yeah it's fine but i don't know that seems
pretty good for him i guess he only has
yeah bishop takes yeah interesting
position hey dude he [ __ ] he was cracked
nice no blunders but quite a few mistakes
i don't feel bad about that though
you're gonna make mistakes when you have no [ __
] clue what the hell to do i've never seen this
opening played exactly i've seen the scandy but
i i don't often see the scandy played with uh a5
the pawn up i guess was the idea
but i hated the idea of pitting
i hated that but i guess there's nothing to attack
so this guy's whatever whatever whatever whatever
he looked like an engine first 15
moves i think he just prepared a line
and props to him because i think it's a hell
of a line that was a really good line i thought
anyway uh how's it going let's double check
let's double check double check double check
there's only one real reason that you try to
beat mr beast and it's for those sweet sweet
subscribers so let's get a live subscriber count
real time ludwig versus mr beast what do we
have here shirley shirley i am catching up
i have to be
let's take a look
any moment now you're about to start seeing
this number on the left just rocket ship away
ludwig versus mr beasts you know it's it's like
pewdiepie versus t series pewdiepie vs coco melon
pewdiepie picks a lot of fights
this is this is my moment
i think the website's a little
slow it's probably a bit slow
does anyone get to like refresh or
something
do i do diss track
it's not
probably broken website yeah you're probably right
don't unsub from me after i beat mr
beast what do you mean it's because
you need a diss track okay all right
all right yeah [ __ ] yeah i got you um
rappy copyright free oh no i got
a better i got a better rap beat
eat [ __ ] [ __ ] you are bad i am really good
that was all i had i didn't really think too far
into it i was that's kind of a one bar song
sometimes it's good enough to have one bar
sometimes you let the beat do
the talking you know what i mean
any moment now this should go skyrocket
tables are now open for gamblers by the way you
got a minute left for any gamblers gamble away
oh i'm live on chess.com again these
[ __ ] got no content on god hey
[ __ ] at chess.com what's up it's
ludwig you ever notice how they always
go to break and run ads and then they use me for
entertainment well you can help out how so easy
let's talk about making your own hours [ __
] that nine to five [ __ ] let your money
make money how do we let our money make
money introducing mogul moves that's right
if you twitch prime to me right now i'm gonna
be your friend what does that get you some perks
friends with me means you're friends with cycuna
corpse slime what do those three have in common
not much actually but you'll be friends with all
of them and all you got to do is twitch prime
that's right click the subscribe button
see if it says subscribe free and purple
and if it does you're golden ponyboy anyway
let's check on who's priming right now
oh [ __ ] it's my friend
um willis hey willis can't wait to grab
lunch later catch you on the flippity flip
anyway back to the chest content you
guys have a good one see you later
i got like 200 primes it was a [ __ ]
smartest thing i've ever done in my life
i have so many twitch primes now
and there we go again enjoying the sweet sweet
sounds and video of ludwig at the break uh but
now it's time to move on and get get on to
game two well here's what i'm hypothesizing on
tanya if if jimmy's prep was this good as black
getting a better position in the scandinavian
and then finding having the knowledge it seems to
to to also know how to approach this middle game
the rook g8 move if his prep was this
good as black what's he gonna do is white
this this is gonna be interesting
yeah and look i mean ludwig's gotta be
scared and one approach the ludwig could take
is to brave something that he doesn't
normally play because it seems that
yeah beast got an amazing position and if they
get into something theoretical you know beast
could end up being winning that's the danger of
falling into something like that when you're black
right well i called him a one-trick pony and
he delivered right no i'm kidding but he did
he did also get the win lovely jokes aside he
handled uh beast prep and then and then and
then cleaned up nicely that was impressive from
lubbock shows his experience and where he's come
which is really why we do the event it's
awesome obviously to grow the game and to
bring the love of chess to a bunch of different
streamers and entertainers of different categories
uh but watching someone improve like ludwig has
and how he like cleaned that up with pre-moving
his way to victory that was badass that's all i'm
going to say oh good stuff it was but what's not
badass is the fact that he's taking 30 seconds on
move one and beast beast trotting out the d4 we
don't see that often in pop gems i think lubbock's
about to pull a oblique the game has started oops
no maybe not he played d5 we saw we saw jimmy give
a fist pump there he was expecting d5 so we'll see
mcqueen's gambit that might
be a first chimp's history
uh he plays queen's gamut i ignore
the gamut [ __ ] that gambit no cap
this dude's so cracked the [ __
] is going on this tournament
can someone be bad at the game
i don't need to defend this
i could play maybe this move
it might allow him to do something
like this but i think that's fine
okay double defended
so good i could go here now what
you went you went to the dark side
best in small doses jimmy playing well we're
in it we're in a chagoran decline which i don't
think is exactly what love would prep but for
those who speak speak fluid chess knight to c6
is a chagoran defense by black it's not not that
well known or common even at the highest levels
um but then bishop five this this could get spicy
if beast is aware of ideas that involve queen b3
right donnie if he plays queen b3 at any point
taking advantage of the light squares that'll
really make me tip my hat to the coaching and the
time he's putting because that would really show
an understanding of the dangers developing
the light square bishop in a queen's gambit
and i'm already tipping my head i mean i'm not
wearing a hat but if i had one and uh this is a
very interesting approach taken by beast he said
he's playing unconventional openings um that he
knows better than his opponent now the problem
danny with the queen's gamut is that it's it's not
like the roof can come down for ludwig even if he
plays inaccurately the worst that's gonna happen
to him is that he's gonna end up being you know
slightly worse or even if he's clearly worse there
is no attack on the horizon so he's pretty solid
here and beast developing his bishop no that's a
really good point it's it's not as dangerous as it
was for him on the white side of that scandinavian
we just had even though uh beast wasn't able
to convert on it it was it was more potentially
dangerous this is going to be very solid i totally
agree with you um reminder to everyone tuning in
these guys threw down a ten thousand dollar bet
started by ludwig on twitter this morning and uh
beast backed it live in an interview before
the match started so there's a lot on the line
what are they gonna do with that 10k if it's going
to go to charity you can donate to charity use the
command charity command donate in in the chat
real quick to get information because that'll
give you a link to the article where you can
see all the charities chosen by our streaming
celebrities so if you are up for donating
obviously we have some big and lofty goals
we do appreciate it and use the commands
charity or donate to get information
folsom a f my let's say okay i'm just
going to you're allowed to say af
but all right wholesome af it means
atlantic fried right atlantic fried chicken
i thought it meant atlantic um fog that's like a
type of coffee and yeah but atlantic now now that
i'm on the east coast yeah atlantic is would
say as af a lot as af which makes about as
much sense as af so there you go um all right
a6 andy6 played by lud a solid move faux show
just controlling some squares he
he likes to stop knight b5 mm-hmm
talk to any no you talking about
explain enlightenment you and i
could talk and not talk for hours that's
the best part about our relationship
indeed indeed and you know what i should be
rooting for beast from the perspective of i
think that he actually lives in north carolina so
i i think he's gonna win the state championship
pretty soon i mean the way that he's playing
right now danny he's he's doing everything right
is that a shade on north uh north carolina
chess or just beast beast's ballardness
i mean north carolina chess
is is in the gutter basis
i was gonna say don't they have a
grandma no especially after that horrible
i heard about it a terrible coach and uh
ruined the career of a successful youtuber
you know yeah no it's just a sad sad story indeed
indeed indeed we'll learn more about that later
94 played by blood so he moves a piece
twice in the opening instead of developing
for the kids watching that's a no-no right don't
do that get your pieces developed get castle
but let's see what ludwig is saying and how he
justifies his current behavior on camera dear god
i think what he might do is
also bring out the bishop
but that's fine for me i think
because if he brings out bishop
i might just [ __ ] pop this [ __ ] open you
know what i mean like this this seems like
a close position chest music is growing
at me he brings out this bishop i take
threading the queen he has to take i can take
here he takes with the queen i pop this bad
boy out okay he does what i want though pawn
or bishop i want the pawn to take because i
want to one make sure that this is dominated
by me and two i want to keep this tension
and i also attack this which can be good
um for me so now we're bad boy out with a hope to
castle he'll probably do something similar
with his bishop maybe he brings it out here
super impressed with beast and impressed with
ludd i'm this is awesome seriously go ahead daniel
yeah no we're not just saying it i mean uh the
thing is most of these players are familiar with
e4 openings and for them to play high level
chess after one d4 in a position they're less
familiar with is uh is is amazing that's it's
awesome and you know what else is awesome danny
is all those donations coming in uh we
really appreciate it this is great to see
yeah uh we gave a uh an organic call to action
because we were speculating one of these
guns is going to do with their 10k uh remember
there's 10 000 on the line that they threw down
this morning but um really really do appreciate it
obviously we're going to continue to see that we
know that some of the players have even been
public on social media that they're going to
donate their winnings to charity i know uh my boy
bobby logic said that on his twitter account last
week um and so it's awesome it's a big another
a big part of why we're doing this so thank you
again of the community now now we'll focus on the
chess and appreciate all the donations coming in
um all right 95 so beast kind of meets ludwig's
night knight e4 and says i'll raise you one
and also move my knight twice in the opening and
again the main thing i think is that either player
probably should have just developed and gotten
castled a more more principled thing but i also
kind of like that they're both being aggressive
and looking for an opportunity here i mean if if
beast takes with the bishop we have a borderline
symmetrical game here of good chess by both sides
you know what's hilarious let me blow your mind
for a second if white takes on e5 of the bishop
which i assume mr beast will please don't take
with the pawn and ruin this and then if ludwig
plays c5 we literally have an a yeah so if ludwig
plays c5 here it is literally symmetrical to the
to the last pawn now we'll do that i don't know
he won't i think he'll do it just for the kicks
and gigs of it that that's you know lug is used to
throwing for content no he didn't okay never mind
all right 56. it would have been a terrible
move it would not have been a terrible move
but this is this is double
edged by itself i'm not saying
this is even the best move objectively but
grabbing this pawn is super dangerous right
um beast could even look to play moves like
queen h5 or queen g4 this is this is spicy
and these guys are both dead luck on the clock
i think mr beast is saying hey i'm not i'm not
going to be the weakest player in this group
like maybe a lot of people thought i might be
right no and and we've seen that from a lot of
players so far like i said ratings don't tell
the whole story we even saw that uh danny as
far back as as pogchamps one we saw people
like i don't know why i remember him
specifically but someone like slicker
who you know you're rating maybe 500
but listen listen listen listen listen
uh he was actually pretty good so bishop
takes g7 beast going for it that was a pretty
good little did you just post out a mini
slicker impression that no one saw coming
yeah i don't really practice it but you know cut
me some slack i'm just looking for an excuse to
do more impressions most of the things i remember
about slicker from pog one cannot cannot be talked
about although who am i kidding we have the
parental advisory below chess tv for a reason
reminder if you're watching there is a parental
advisory there you know what show you're getting
into welcome to pogchamps 3 presented by
grip6 here we go uh rook rook to g8 um
so lud does the right thing on bishop g7 bishop
e5 is kind of the only move or the best move but
man this is about to get about
to get real spicy i think
yeah so the bishop is hanging
right bishop has to well probably
mr beast will move the bishop he might
move it back to e5 and then ludwig
has his sights aimed at that g2 fun but he's
got to be very careful because if he takes
that pawn he might actually get pinned by
white stroke so there's a lot going on here
and ludwig might choose to prioritize his
development which is what i would do yeah
oh
it's not the worst move from an idea perspective
everyone because he's trying to trade bishop for
bishop right and and that's a lot of times where
the calculation stops but the reason donde and i
both grimace is because if lugwood goes all the
way to see queen h4 check at the end of the line
things could get to get really interesting here
um and ludwig might already be looking at a check
like that let's let's take a listen in and see
what lud is thinking about this pawn i take here
i literally did the wrong one i literally said
out loud what i was going to do i think this
is fine though but [ __ ] but obviously i
just talked about [ __ ] up the structure
frustrating frustrating to play bad man
now the check will be very strong on h4
in here i could do a tactic though that's the
kind of awesome things we do on the fly my team
letting me know yeah cutie's cheering on her man
and my producer that's right making it happen
right on my cue look at that cutie's got
commentary going and now she's going to mirror
herself it's going to be awesome let's watch it
look at that right on my channel look at that
he's got commentary on it now she's going to take
me off your screen this is so embarrassing i'm
not wearing makeup and i'm eating cheese this is
not please go to twitch.tv slash cutie cinderella
chat everybody here go to twitch.tv cinderella
and hit the follow button down there before she
um okay and she ain't too shabby herself
okay she's working on her chest too all
right we're back seriously she's awesome
if you haven't followed her channel
go go give it go give it your follow alright g3
was played this was the line i was predicting
right with with uh queen h4 check john did
this is oh he finds bishop takes g3 even better
the brook is hanging wow i mean it's just crazy
and that is just devastation being reeked upon
black sting that was the whole point of queen h4
check and you can just tell by his eyes he has
his eyes are aimed right at white's king right at
white's king's side and despite the best efforts
of mr beast i mean blood is just he's earning
this one danny he's got to take our hats off
he's played so well and i i i don't want it
to be the story line i want a bag on blood
i can't wait for that no i'm kidding no i i
love the guy and this is this is his chest
look how good he's gotten here i mean
he doesn't even settle on queen e4
he sees the pin takes on g3 and and this is
just an awesome thing to see where he's uh he's
gonna go to and jimmy has played super well mr
b says has surprised and had obviously some some
great ideas his openings were good but ludwig
just right now just that much that much better
absolutely and you know miguel tall right whom
ludwig tries to model his games after you know who
his favorite uh music musical composer was he was
asked once and in a fit of inspiration he said
ludwig van beethoven yeah that was i was i was
cooking that up for hours danny dude so this
is my moment in the sun there's a reason we have
bad pun emotes for you like on multiple channels
well i gotta live up to my name i'm literally
the punchline i haven't been awkward
i'm the punchline of the most awkward
cringe-worthy moments we've ever had
in chess but you dude you just jumped into
the top five with that that was awesome ugh
i'm if i make another bad pun my hair myself might
start falling out and then i'll need a blood wig
who do you want to thank for these
i mean that was pretty good i'm just
oh i'm dying inside and this is my
job to make people feel this way bro
wow who do you want to thank for for how
far you've come with your bad pun game
it's you know it takes a village danny it takes
it takes many people to allow me to descend
to such to such depths it's really it's taken
many years of practice all right well um well
what's going on here budwig is playing fantastic
chess he won the exchange with bishop takes g3
a five head tactic cleaning up now even plays
queen takes e4 here which i think is even better
than taking i mean g3 is also on the agenda but i
like that he gets the queen into a strong position
he's playing some of the best chess i've ever seen
him play seriously yeah he's playing amazing and
look at the time consumption he's not playing
too fast but he's not playing too slow he's got
half his time left and unfortunately beast
one of the things that brought him down is
just you know he's got a
minute on the clock and uh for
i mean beast is is very very impressive and
he's going to train a little bit more danny
he's going to have a serious shot at
winning some of these uh future matches
yeah and maybe the whole event i mean obviously
we've been talking about who the strongest players
are um super super hard to predict right now but
i mean this is this is the kind of chess that
it gets you pog champs belts yep that's just
although i'll say this if ludwig wins he might
be the one person i refuse to send this to i'd
lock it up make him come get it himself right
absolutely make a cross-country trip out of it
all right queen takes g3 you know just like beth
wow yep check king has to get out this is this
is a massacre black is not actually up we'll
back us up in exchange in a couple pawns but more
importantly is the time situation you know what
would be a pretty uh pretty cool move here danny
castle's long okay he just keeps getting checks
castles long would be the uh the right way
to bring this thing to a close for sure
the middle of the heated attack
terrible how could he miss that
defended defended here must
interpose oh that worked out well
i would say so pre-move it because i think
it's forced oh my god it now goes too much
uh we're checking again here next level
stuff and we'll check again here grab pawn
like i said too much among us who is this
imposter uh we're going for a mate there's
a bad fun for you how's that the bullet world
champion wow instant chess wow mopping it up here
oh my gosh um holy [ __ ] sick oh my lance oh
let's go dude never have i felt so good on a
chess board i've i felt so calm today that
was great that was good chess oh yes it was
i'm speechless oh my lens i'm speechless my my
throat is dry a lot of people said that brain
wilson was maybe the clear favorite to win but
you know what dwight schrute has to say about that
because i could use some nice gaia key for mate
it totally use some of that as well to
enjoy with some of the park champions
just made a statement and said rayne
wilson is not the favorite and pog
champs will be presented by grip six white
fruit says false and we'll be right back
come
you win this
oh i mean poo whoops sorry chest viewers my bad
behave yeah my bad my bad my bad pg-13
hey chess people are you ready
to watch our matchstick against
is it bad if i just insta
forfeit two games in a row
no well that's why that's why you're
a big gaping whiner no you're a racist
nice
yo 127. what do you mean let's count
from the front
all right guys come on bye
around and uh let's pick it up
i'm gonna start working long from now on
yo do you still play omen not really
because kiljoy's meta so i play brim
if i need a blind pick you want to hear my
omen impression snuff them out lick my nuts
i didn't hit him at all needing him
one enemy remaining where's jed i want
satchel last guy i think would mark it
hold on nice job everybody
there is yo how big are my eyes
what how big are my eyes uh they're they're
just i don't know as bad as a monster
i'm just not gonna talk about eyes anymore because
i understand that's a sore topic for all of you
what are you talking about literally
nothing i'm just saying raise just stop
i will i don't [ __ ] trust
me oh okay i got you i got you
to flash pipes jet is in ct careful
wait that's not pipes uh one trouble
you didn't you know you didn't pop it
right yeah i know i [ __ ] think thank you
did you see that post on reddit gold yes
hook it up bro watch i'm gonna fake flash i'm
gonna all and then i'm gonna fake flash okay
all right all right all right
one showers oh they're like
heaven omen is heaven a heaven
close he's there heaven
he's triple
[ __ ] leg someone random in your chat but
if you want charity that's not [ __ ] them
yeah give it to charity my chat's
going to be so sad right now
they probably just blogging out of their mind
nah [ __ ] them on god they're good they're good
they're good you heard it here first folks [ __
] his chat [ __ ] my chat hey they know i'm the
one who says it to the most but uh either way
my man um hype games i think i think your path
is just easy crushing the consolation
bracket which is where all the hype is
at anyway from my experience uh yeah well
yeah that's a nice way of saying i suck
but no danny will danny will back me
up here going to the losers bracket
was a decision i made in the last pog champs
all the good players and he almost won
yeah i lost to charlie in the finals and it
had more viewers than the winner's bracket
because no one gave a [ __ ] because it
has like irrelevant streamers like you know
uh i'll do some call outs sure sardoche uh
daniel negranu the [ __ ] is that boomer uh
you're uh doing the lord's work you're
making sure you get to the finals so
i have to go to the finals because i have
a chess coach and he would beat my ass if
i didn't go there so this is purely for hey i
went up against the man with the chest coach
i enjoyed this next year here next year can you
put it where i play him again first round if we
both make it next year i'm down next year i will
train i'll give myself a chest coach i'll learn
your first seven moves not your first six i'll go
all out that's gonna be the game changer all right
one year one year from today we rematch in chess
and we uh we put we put we put high stakes on it
i'll give you my stream key and you give me your
just give me your youtube channel oh uh yeah you
can have like the reaction channel this is getting
next year we've got channels with 10 mil bro
we've got pogchamps coming up we'll do another
one later this year so uh but anyway guys uh
almost almost 99 of that golden banter was was
off stream but we caught the end of it i heard
you say ludwig you're going to donate your 10k
to charity or beast can choose the charity of
his choice oh you guys were offline well we were
online on my editing reels were offline yeah i
i don't want mr beast to give me 10k i wanted to
go give it to charity and go make another hype
but you forgot the most important part though
he specifically said [ __ ] his chat yes
he did offer the money to my chat and
i said [ __ ] him on god and i hope
by that statement okay well before your eyes
everybody you can see all the charities that
our streaming celebrities have chosen so there are
some really specific ones that are based on their
local community and kind of really near and dear
in their hearts there are some more well-known
um global charities there we see mr b security st
jude's obviously we're raising money you can use
the charity command or the donate command in chat
we do appreciate all your love and it's all gone
um okay back to the chess uh mr beast
that was that was no that wasn't
what you said no just start it was epic you were i
mean donya and i were blown away by by the opening
prep and then i heard you say to ludwig you know
off off stream here that you literally he's like a
he's more than a one-trick pony i mean you could
download his games and you've got a map to victory
right but then what happened for you after the
openings where you really started to take a lot
of time and then you weren't sure what to do right
yeah so uh like i was saying to his stream but for
the people who are watching on the chess stream um
i basically just looked at all his like recent 50
games and just he does the same thing every time
based on how you respond so i had i practiced
with my friends i was like just do this when i do
this and so like i practiced like 50 games like
the first six moves but i never played past that
part and so that i just kept i was like all right
we're gonna get here and then every time we got
there from that point on i just fell apart every
game because i i don't practice a fraction as
much as he does he's obviously the better player
next year whenever we do this again though i'm
really gonna i'm gonna get a coach and take it
seriously but you you got pressured obviously by
his prep but then you held on because obviously we
were really applauding jimmy's uh preparation
and his approach at this point but even more
impressive was the fact that you kind of handled
this and you didn't get down on time and you you
kept your head so what were you thinking did you
kind of you smelt a rat that he was prepared but
what was going through your head me yeah oh
dude game one so back up a bit if you go to
like i forget the move but i felt like he could
have gone knight a similar trick i did earlier
to b4 and i was stressed out about that and then
when i attacked his queen uh a little bit later uh
i was also stressed out that um that he would
just take with his pawn and ignore his queen
and then he would fork my queen and rook and i was
stressed out about that this position here yeah i
kept getting into ugly situations and all i said
to myself i was like damn hope you don't do that
and he did it and he did it and he ended up
thankfully just uh giving away the queen here but
uh he found himself in a beautiful spot here i
felt like [ __ ] i mean if he just took with that
pawn there that knight that bishop and i i get a
queen from it but i lose three minor pieces that's
uh not that great it's equivalent in points but
it's pretty down in terms of uh his attack that'll
have on me i felt really bad but thankfully it's
not what happened yep but thankfully i suck yeah
well i think i think shockingly i think uh you are
like really good positionally which is like weird
and i am only good like tactically and so you
always got in better positions but i just don't
think you had like the uh which i think is just
a practice thing straight up i think you know
if we combine our talents we make one decent chess
player yeah if yeah that's what i'm saying that's
i'm going to secretly wiretap you in on a zoom
call for every future chess match to hopefully
help you be happy beat everyone but then you had
a great position again as as white uh and so what
was what was the prep here right we saw that
you got a great position and ludd by the way
that's some five head analysis i mean dude you're
literally seeing the board super well because
you're totally right he could have he could have
gone for this and he didn't so in the next game
you also had some prep mr beast but where where
did it go wrong here or where did you not know
anymore uh in terms of what he was going to do uh
so if you just i can tell you just rewind it to
the start what color am i white i could literally
so i i go d4 first and then he always mirrors it
yeah and then then i moved my uh yeah that pawn
and then he always moves one of his knights out
and then i i move one of mine and i'm pretty
sure his next move is to move a night out right
right or that hurt and he likes yeah and
he likes to uh then i probably moved my
other night and then he likes to move his light
square bishop out somewhere so cold out right now
and a lot of the games i saw he would put it on d7
but i i was whenever he did this he would put it
there um and now i'm starting to draw a blank it's
easier to remember when i'm like actually playing
um but yeah you can like get to this part and
i asked like uh gotham i was like is this good
for me and he's like yeah this is a good position
and so i was like all right i made it my objective
just to get this board right here and then um
yeah just keep developing pieces so i can castle
danya after that nice for jimmy the
next time he gets this against ludwig
well i think one thing you could do
is you could take that pawn if we
actually go back to the very beginning after
knight f6 move two taking the pawn on d5 is
a good idea piece and then following
up by controlling the center with e4
um what do you have to say to that ludwig is your
eskian game manual helping you deal with that
uh yeah because i would go back and then you know
what here's my take i and this is why i play the
same thing every time openings are [ __ ] and no
one gives a [ __ ] as long as you get all your
pieces out and you control the center right no
one here is good enough to hold the lead we saw
rayne wilson choke 18 different ways so as long as
i don't make a giant blunder if positionally i am
down because there's one theoretical line where
if donya was in this spot he would walk down to
this win i'm fine so i my thought process was hey
let's just get my shits out let's just do my thing
i will say what it did screw me on was time oh my
god i was so slow i was molasses because i had to
think really hard but uh i i wasn't i wasn't too
worried as long as i didn't make a giant mistake
well let's talk about the time you play i
was i was singing your praises even though
it was against every fiber of my being my
being i was singing your praises and i was
saying that one of the things you get credit
for is that when he kind of out prepped you
you you handled the clock super
well you never got way down on time
was that a conscious effort are you working
on that like what what was the deal it was
way down on time and then i was like i gotta
go faster and so i just started planning out
moves but they weren't good ones so like that's
like where i ran into the bishop attacking queen
i planned that attack but it wasn't a good attack
and i knew that but it's all i could think of and
so uh same with when he took uh game two bishop
and then he went to uh take the pawn on what was
it like g7 whatever that is uh and i brought my
rook out i thought that was all so bad because it
you know it didn't it worked out tactically
because i had a few things that happened but
i was i don't think my moves were good i just had
a plan and i stuck to it and i tried to play quick
you did it at the end we were impressed with your
speed and your accuracy at the end whatever it
is you're doing maybe you are cracking open
doretsky's engine manual keep doing it but
not to take anything away from you that
was a great opening great play all around
yeah beast young god young guy i
don't know how you have the time man
oh anyway now that you followed me on twitter
i'm gonna dm you daily for advice on thumbnails
let's do it what what's your next video or
actually i probably probably don't want this
on a chest stream youtube strategy my next video
is how i beat mr beast for ten thousand dollars uh
oh that's a banger he carves most of your
videos him [ __ ] on me in chess wait really
yeah yeah interesting interesting ten thousand
dollar things that happen let's bring it up
you want to put a picture of me like about
to cry in the thumbnail because then people
will think i'm like pissed off all right
yeah we'll help carl bully you for a while
well you guys uh you added the stakes and um i
know it's a lot of fun in games but seriously
i mean it's another ten thousand dollars to
charity big reason why we're doing this you
guys are awesome thank you um jimmy i know i know
you're going to keep working on it and jokes aside
seriously that was super impressive and i agree
with ludwig i don't even know that it has to be in
the constellation bracket i think you're i think
your pogchamps future is bright bud i i don't know
what to say man i i don't know who you are anymore
like who is this imposter like what is going on
with you just keep doing it i guess just studying
a bit here and there all i gotta say is one final
message to chat if you guys go out and beat
danny's bot on chess.com he'll give you a free
diamond membership if you screenshot it instead of
proof everybody let's do it no one can do that and
everybody's already beaten your bot and they've
sent it to me i got so many diamond memberships i
got to give away is ridiculous dude my butt trash
what do you want from me just says the plan is
simple and then chokes all right well this isn't
over all right guys all right good luck guys later
everybody you're awesome thank you guys pleasure
to see you we'll see you in your next match thanks
all right that was awesome all right indeed
that was crazy high quality chess and
if only we had one more matchup
danny but wait we actually we do
yeah i mean honestly what you said is true that
uh the chess was awesome and shout out to to
levy rosman i didn't know if i was allowed to say
that he was he was uh mr b's secret coach but then
uh jimmy revealed it himself he worked with gotham
so in addition to apparently doing a good strategy
what do you think about that strategy john
of play having your friends play a bunch of
games with the opening moves of your opponent
right which is how he helped apparently that
helped him memorize in addition to working with
levy this morning which is awesome um i i think
that jimmy's future in this event may surprise
people especially after what we just saw here
that's some next level scouting that's uh you
know russian grand master kind of territory and uh
his own players are awesome he's showing
well he's getting there though i mean he
he predicted what ludwig is going to
do he's better out of both games so
uh he's definitely going to say going to
make his presence felt this pock jams and
he's going to be a fixture uh for
sure as he gets more training it
yeah uh for sure and and it was awesome i can't
wait for both of them to play their next masters
but we also have one more match today don't go
anywhere chat pog champs three presented by grip
six continues in just a few moments introducing
the grip 6 belt the only belt on the market with
the no gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so light
and thin that you'll barely even notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes this belt
the most comfortable belt in the world overly
confident much you're damn right because on top
of being the most comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear and damn
tee meaning if you don't like any belt for any
reason at any time or in any condition you can
just contact us and we'll give you a full refund
welcome in guys
i know we're go i'm going up against the top
seed in our bracket right now so it's like oh
we're gonna try to do our best that's what
that's our focus do our best for today's match
do our absolute best
um
oh okay
you got that [ __ ] don't worry i'm ready
i mean i'm not i'm gonna try my best
we'll see what happens we're
gonna try i'm gonna try my best
i like to move
awesome different music real quick
oh boy
did you get another lesson
with maurice i did a little
lesson with maurice after our first
one but other than that not really
um no okay
there we go
reach deep into yerba mate culture and
you discover people have long gathered
to imbibe mate to awaken the mind perform
extraordinary feats and exchange confidences
brewed from the naturally caffeinated and
nourishing leaves of the species of holly
native to the south american atlantic rainforest
come to life with guayaqui's wide assortment of
yerba mate offerings all with
powers to unite and energize
and we are back here we've had a lot of new
subscribers today thank you for that support um
and it also gives you access to the gaia key emote
in chat and if you didn't know ayaki there yerba
mate is celebrating 25 years as your favorite
regenerative beverage they're sharing cases to
celebrate they're not kidding i've got a ton in
the office and i poured it into my white fruit
mug and damn was that stuff delicious it doesn't
have corn syrup i don't know if you know that i'm
an anti-corn syrup guy i freaking loved the gaia
key or bramate and i'm gonna keep drinking it and
a lot of our players and commentators have gotten
some too so you can get some cases if you spam the
emotes but you got to start doing it right now
another thing we're going to do right now is
talk about hand in brain dania naraditsky what's
your favorite part of hand and brain as a format
what i love the most is uh when one person
very vehemently wants one move and then the
other person plays another move and that anger
and suppressing that because you got to keep the
chemistry going you can't just yell at someone
and what i also love is the person playing a
different move than originally intended but that
move turns out to be better so right there's so
much that's really cool about that dynamic no i
love that you just said that the biting of the
of the tongue so to speak when like you don't want
to ruin your chemistry with your you know higher
rate or lower rate of partner so you don't get
you don't get pissed but you're clearly unhappy
um but uh anyway that's awesome just a reminder
the twitch rivals event on march 2nd will have 35
000 in prize money homie um a lot of your favorite
streamers both of the variety and other game
category and chess will be in it budwig boy boy
our first ever pogchamps champion will be back
motez live at hicarro are involved all kinds
of awesome chess streamers and members of other
categories like i said so mark your calendar
for march 2nd all right donya myth and a guy
that has come out of nowhere and been on the grind
establishing himself as maybe the favorite to win
it all in in the french streaming sardosh and then
you've got myth who's getting better with every
show he started doing lessons with maurice ashley
um your thoughts on the matchup we're about to see
well definitely sardosh pulling pulling ahafu
he's been grinding i mean the legends have been
going around uh but obviously i wouldn't sleep
on myth i mean we've already seen this play out
again and again uh it's easy to underestimate
someone when uh you've got his opponent grinding
like sardoch does he's clearly the favor danny i
think there's no denying that but i think the game
you know when the bright lights are shining uh the
game is often closer than uh you know it seems to
be on paper yep no and that happened in the first
match with nico sardoche um ultimately did prove
to be the better player you know he he got the the
w but nico um hikara and i were saying i mean she
had some moments where her intuition her feel for
for certain things was not only spot on but her
speed was super impressive maybe it actually kind
of backfired if she had slowed down a little bit
with some of the advantages she had sardosh maybe
not you know maybe not uh have walked away with a
victory there so um so yeah i think uh i think
myth knows he's the underdog but he's here to
continue to rock and get better he's enjoying it
and sardosh sodosha admitted he was he was nervous
after that uh after that um first match with
nico so he knows there's a lot of pressure on him
and yeah all right we uh we're a
couple of minutes away from game time
your thoughts on your mate yeah it's your point
about pressure this stuff all the time
i'm just getting into it i had no idea
i've i've been having for years actually um truly
and i like the taste it's uh it's pleasant and uh
people on my stream know that i don't you
know i don't give my approval to something
that i don't actually like uh and also it has
the word mate and in many languages obviously
that means nate so you gotta drink something that
contains the word mate so grand master approved
your puns are just i mean i'm so past the
point of cringing i'm like i'm just impressed
i mean it's uh it just comes naturally you
know it just comes it's it's my greatest talent
let's see shall we say well now that's too i was
going to include the name myth but um yeah it's
it's it's as stale as a can of star sardines or
sort of star doge or doughy i just i need to i
need to stop start talking i've struggled
with how to say his name a lot uh sardash
yeah french not my specialty yeah
but sardo sounds pretty natural
yes it's easier for me to speak american
um it's english but okay russian media
but easier for me to say russian
names but okay french is not so easy
um all right well the uh the chat is ready we've
got myth in his normal streaming setup where his
fans have grown to know and love him dardoch is
um sometimes he gets so focused he goes full fobby
full fabiano where all we got is the forehead
and the hairline i'd never go full fabi fobby but
they become close yeah wow and uh that's he
is a grinder and you can see his rating here
wow that's he's almost 1400 danny that's pretty
darn impressive he is pulling a happo by the way
apparently the reason why the games haven't
started is because sardoche started a practice
game which is why we're tuning in to watch
because that is actually his live game
oh wow you can't get enough training
smith is like i stopped my games and
then he started one what is going on
this is crazy he's not doing too well here but
he's getting the the l's out out of the way
uh he's almost 1400 rapid is
guy is put in the time
oh he's going to get checkmated though yeah
if 68 is found it's it's it's rover red rover
and yeah he's just got to get
the blunders out of the way
yeah he's going to resign oh i like it all in
french whoa he's starting another game oh did
you start another game someone go aborts okay
good the staff reported did he play the game
danny did i just see somebody shut down that
man's ability to start games there we go i
love how we keep aborted oh now we started
the myth game okay there we go nice game on
guys you're right it was just i gotta
get another game i gotta get another game
oh yeah that was all right yup
but he plays the grub now that is
we'll see what he does with white now he's
uh sort of playing black here myth is white
and an open sicilian day okay i'd rather have
it open sicilian than a close sicilian i say
um i don't know where that came from and
no that was a very wise statement i'm still
you know i'm still considering its implications
and and orf played by sardosh and the knight of is
sort of a big boy opening it's just not something
you waltz into if you haven't studied openings
it's very theoretical you got to know a lot of
stuff and uh e6 he's playing it professionally
so far after seeing the first one and i know
that nico uh he held her own in that match
ultimately got the draw in the end um but seeing
seeing some of the tactics that sardosh unhurled
this rook takes g2 thing um and and just the way
he's playing this opening here i mean i don't
think there's any question anymore as far as time
this guy is putting in and how strong he is yeah
for sure and these pawns on e6 and d16 are called
the kevin ingen structure i think it's named after
a a city i think in the in the netherlands where
and you'll see that some openings and structures
are named after cities and usually that's because
uh there was a tournament held in that city
where that particular opening was was sort of
first played but i'm actually impressed and i
don't mean to sound like a broken record but i'm
honest here myth is developing his pieces in a
really nice way he's positioned his pawns kind of
like a vampire teeth clamping down on the center
but and there it is jinx may strike again i'm
not a big fan of that one yeah i agree with you
um i was about to compliment in the same way and
highlight that you talked about the chevron ingot
structure if we talk about myth structure this
is known as a meroxybind structure clamping down
like you said particularly on the light squares
if method just played knight c3 and a lot of the
moves here are very natural you put the rooks in
the center the queen finds any number of squares
and white typically has an edge just just like
the the eval bar says queen a4 is one of those
moves that sometimes happens for inexperienced
players where after doing the logical things
they they want to be all right well now i got
to go do something got to be aggressive i think
it takes a while for the patients to to come in
where you realize actually doing something good is
sometimes just building your strength developing
your pieces behind your furthest advanced pawns
and not having to look to to make aggressively
you know optically aggressive looking moves so
anyway but i do like the last couple moves by myth
and i think we have a very equal middle game ahead
we absolutely do he dials it back which is good
makes sure that all his pieces are safe now so i
know she's probably going to develop his knight
he's got one more piece left to develop and my
guess is he's probably attracted by knight g4 no
he develops his knight uh and then he might bring
his rook into ca and x-ray the queen that would be
one way the plaque could continually put pressure
on white center now black is cramped but that's
kind of the point you don't have to have a lot
of space in chess to have a good position black's
got a lot of ways that he can break through and uh
white's pieces could end up being overextended
very well said and i think this is a critical
moment so let's let's go in and see how mr tsm
myth is doing in terms of what he's thinking about
fascinating
okay are my headphones working
focused yes it's a weird game
hey he said something very very tight-knit here
like i wonder when this is
all going to explode you know
okay maybe that's when all right
maybe maybe the time is soon
he understands that this is
intense this position is wow
and decide knight d2 would be better but the
reason is kind of complicated oh i just did it
but now sardo says this move knight to a5 knight
to the side attacking the queen queen has to move
and then you win that pawn on c4 yeah he will
he find what was the best move several moves
if he had played knight c3 but the position
got specific enough where the knight on d2
was the better square but i don't know that sardo
should have seen a five pawn i move my bishop here
there's no threat right you might play knight
e5 instead he might want to go to the center
but he does get the move back it's not like a
crazy thing but it does help advance i think
i think i want to go for a palm
break here it's just so intense danny
e5 oh okay he's he's trying
to go for the first one
that shows you let's come back to the board here i
mean that that shows you even even though sardoce
has been applauded for the night orphan obviously
one of the stronger players maybe the man to beat
this shows you that even for him donya
once he did the opening correctly
kevin ingan his lack of experience right there's
only so many book smarts you can have right your
actual experience is another thing it's hard to
know what to do with these pawn structures because
often here for black as well he should have
been patient or found your 985 move and just
built strength it's hard to sit on a center
sometimes as you're learning the game and e5
was a potentially a very bad move because of these
light square problems here for black yeah you're
you're absolutely on the money danny and that as
you said is the danger of playing these openings
where you have to think creatively in order to
play well and i love what myth did here knight to
f5 he's playing aggressively purposefully and that
d5 square is indeed very very weak now sardoche
i mean he doesn't have to take the knight but
it probably would be a good idea to get that
knight off the board he's also got a little
bit less time so we kind of called it you know
all of these games are a lot closer than they
may appear on paper no 100 i mean we've we've had
a lot of surprises in in a lot of good ways where
every i mean mr beast last time and we had uh
now we've got i mean this is a this is a position
where objectively if you forgot who the players
are i mean white white has a lot of potential here
to be much better this d5 square is going to be
a problem for the rest of the game and it's also
almost an easier position for myth to play because
this bishop is bad this square is weak like black
has more long-term problems that would take a
lot of experience to outmaneuver vice position
is kind of just easier to play here right now
it absolutely is you could bring the rooks in you
could prepare to position the knight on d5 i agree
and that is being reflected in the time
consumption sardoche not concerning yet but he
takes two more minutes you know then things start
getting a little bit dicey for him and if i were
him i would put a rook on c8 i would try to create
some threats do something tricky maybe target that
c4 pawn that moved to the side of the board knight
a5 is still interesting but it's not a move that's
easy to see danny if you're not very familiar with
this position as you were talking about yep you
know and it's already lost some of its punch it
was it obviously would have won the pawn earlier
when the queen had nowhere to go now if you play
95 the queen can even make the most natural move
for a player of a lot of levels queen a4 and black
is in trouble so this will be a good test can myth
maintain i was just going to say can he maintain
the time advantage and just and just play quick
logical moves this isn't this isn't a totally bad
move but it's it's definitely overly aggressive
and if sardosh sees knight g4 oh man suddenly
the dark squares are backfiring for white so
um again this is one of those signs we talk about
where players learn over time like once you have
an advantage sometimes the simplest moves are how
you build on that strength i keep using that term
you're building your pieces behind your
pawns for their potential rather than
kind of lashing out for one move threats
and and um anyway still totally anybody's
game and i'm just nervous now about what
could happen on the dark squares for myth
likewise and another way to think about why f4 is
not such a good move is because well first of all
you push upon in front of your king not directly
in front of your king but in that general vicinity
which weakens the diagonal and also if
you take a look at that bishop on e3
you've got to be super careful about it because
it's lost its defender now it's undefended
which means that if uh sardocia attacks it
that's another threat that myth has to worry
about sardosh could now take either with the
knight to threaten the d3 bishop or he could
take with a rook to threaten the bishop i was
just talking about i would probably take with the
knight or even the pawn in order to secure that
d4 square in the center yeah agreed on takes here
you know also knight takes hits this bishop
and has a discovery maybe on the next move
which a discovery is when you move a piece to
unleash an attack of another piece behind it so
yeah okay he takes with the rook this is kind of
the most straightforward you feel like you got
to deliver a punch move because it immediately
creates an attack but knight takes actually had
it's more like more like putting gunpowder in the
gun right knight takes was actually a little more
powerful um and because of the discovery tactic
that we talked about okay but either way these
guys are playing really really good chess this is
very close still anybody's game yeah now there's
there's a really awesome of rook takes bishops now
myth has defended it but because he's weak in that
diagonal by pushing his f on uh starters would
take the bishop and play queen to b6 but that's a
super advanced tactic danny and knight g4 is also
really good and here we see myth starting to pay
the price for that weakening move and that is what
could end up really hurting him he's got to be
super careful and the weakening move we're talking
about is that move just a few moments ago f4 if
you're just tuning in or kind of a reminder of the
big picture because if this bishop moves to the
wrong square just to show i mean moves like this
come in and the game is is is almost over because
black is going to grab the dark squares and all
kinds of dangerous things are going to happen
to the white king so this is a very very scary
proposition here okay knight d5 what excellent wow
that is the only move actually that
is the only good way that he finds it
that was huge and it also shows the recognition
that this knight left the square behind so it's
it's the best defense is a good offense right
he defends the bishop and attacks the queen
oh man and he's also of two minutes on the clock
this is gonna come down to the wire below five
minutes now for sardo she spent more than half
his time and we know what happens when these
players they dip it to two minutes one minute
danny they're not as experienced in bullet chest
one minute chess so they start to panic and that
is a very very important consideration two whole
minutes up on the clock myth is looking good here
yeah and if this queen moves to the wrong square
smith could save his dark square bishop and
attack the rook and suddenly you just you look
at snapshot and it feels like all white's pieces
are on really good squares if he owns the e-file
but yeah this is a critical moment for sardosh
and i think he's gonna i think he's gonna spend
on the whole other minute maybe thinking about it
i mean this is this is a tough position and you
can see how zoned in he is let's take a listen
into mitch he's talking to us about his ideas
he's around the map we're on the board
we place this queen up to pressure my
rook it's actually a really good move
actually not if he plays the right response
yeah but it's a strong idea by
sardosh for sure right at least
but like this move doesn't really do
anything because at the end of the
day like i just take his queen well
this isn't really that big of a deal
matter of fact it's actually he just opened up
this rook take for me oh my god he opened up
this pawn for me this was a misplay by him i
think oh my lands i love his thought process
i've been watching him solve puzzles and oh well
i guess he could go for a knife oh no he could go
for my knight maybe that's not what i'm looking
at maybe that's something i'm not looking at is
yeah that might be the kicker
that he's actually going for no
he'll drop the bishop if he moves tonight
yourself
i want to sing like elsa ah so
wait don't move the bishop either
because you'll drop the rook
gonna do it so he's threatening
two pieces at once right now
three pieces actually no
he's starting to see ghosts
actually not threatening
anything i think my best move is
i wonder why he gave up on queen
seven because he said it yeah
he thought the knight was hanging with that pawn
on c4 is defending directly defending the knight
we like that he's taking his time though
because maybe he'll come back to finding
he only has two threatens
all here so maybe if i go knight b6
it'll like divert his attention here
and i have two takes here for his two so
he takes i take take take or if he doesn't
do anything around that and he like plays
around here then i get his knight as well
let's do that let's see how that plays
out maybe that's not the right thing but
it does drop the piece of stardust reacts real
quick he takes that knight that's what there's
so the reason it's losing everybody it was right
about the fact that he has the pieces defending
but exactly he thought that the knight was
crucial defending the bishop and sardosh
doesn't have to be asked twice oh man yeah but
sardosh was in a bit of an inaccurate move though
he allows smith to take the rope cerdo
should have taken the knight first
yeah yeah no you're right he should
have taken it okay so actually
see if myth follows through on the
idea of why the knight moved there
the thing is no you go ahead i was just going to
say quickly that that the in the grand scheme of
things sardosh played the right move because he
can slide his queen over to c5 fair discover check
but i think judging by his facial reaction he
actually missed the fact that the rook was hanging
we'll see right yeah if he finds queen c5 everyone
this this was actually exactly this rook is so
irrelevant to the position you're threatening some
of the most famous baiting nets in the world right
venus fly traps and dart and back rank mates
are on the agenda so if he sees queen c5 uh
just really on track for uh for
a park champs victory i think
that's a really strong move um he's nervous
he's nervous yep and he's only got three minutes
until he's grabbing his head and i think he
missed knight take say that unsettled him
will he gather himself together here d4 is
also not a bad move it shows he recognized
the dark squares but not winning like queen
c5 would have been right now myth has to take
that pawn on d7 his queen queen is under attack
he's got to play aggressively here see that the
pawn on b7 is hanging all right let's listen
and see if myth is on track with that idea
and i could get out of it by taking pawn you go i
could like trust himself it's definitely an option
overthinking it like this is taken i can't move
here i can't move here i can't move anywhere here
can't move here i can't move here
i think the uh i think yeah so
that forces me to go for this pawn i'm
pretty sure [ __ ] all right i take pawn
brilliant i think that's a good move
even like that's my only move there
to get my queen out of danger i feel like i'm
gonna hope he's gotta move into position to attack
queen d2 will be very strong here yeah let's come
back to this show his knights are going to be like
objectively black is still winning queen d2 is
super strong i think even putting the
queen on c5 is still super problematic
but this was an aggressive move that myth needed
to play because if sardosh doesn't convert
bc8 b8 in fact ic2 is exactly the kind of mistake
you can make you could trade and then trade
still have ideas of queen coming in right this
is like but this is anyone's game make no mistake
the eval bar is not important here time scramble
this is what we signed up for now myth has to
take that knight and then take sardocia's rook
otherwise he's going to lose one of these syrups
this is a fork yeah a fork is when a knight or
pawn attacks two pieces at once you can also call
it a double attack but uh this move is is crucial
because it it's going to force myth to have to
stay aggressive and what i was going to compliment
earlier daniel than i we were listening in but one
thing i i've noticed he does is partly because
he solves so much puzzles if does a great job the
moment someone plays a move his first instinct
unlike a lot of people is he always looks for
their threat like you can hear it in his thought
process he talks about the rook right even if he
doesn't see right away that you know the rook is
protected or the knight had protection of c4 pawn
his mindset is very prophylactic he's always
looking for it and i think as he learns different
concepts dania and gets better it's going to
make him a very good player i really believe that
no he's got that correct logic in place
and that just that doesn't come easy and
unfortunately blunders that rope
i think he got attracted danny by
that bishop but the thing is the bishop
isn't hanging it's defended by the queen
and takes the correct rook and the look at the
queen is defending both the knight and the bishop
white is down a piece now his initiative fizzling
out but what an effort in the middle game here
by by myth but sardoche staying strong in the
critical moments and speeding up when he had to
hess talks about this a lot right retreating moves
are just the ones you miss a lot especially in
blitz and this is i think you're 100 right
that's exactly what he missed with queen d7
just literally literary literary and i need to go
back to the school for kids who don't read good
i cannot be literally yet anyway queen d7 just
missed that this was on the agenda and now he's
gonna pay the price i think i think andreas
will win this one with two minutes on the clock
yeah and you can just tell i think he's he's
still nervous but i think he senses that the
game is turned around and now the clock not
myths friend either he's got now down to a minute
unfortunately for white there's no checks
against black skin everything is protected so
just down a piece now white's king
is the one on the chopping block
yeah i see chad saying and agree he's definitely
better than 4.95 the moment some of these things
start coming together myth is gonna make i think
bigger leaps than than people will expect because
he's doing so many things right but um he's
kind of almost too defensive minded in some ways
yeah i mean he you know it's easy for
us to say you got to trust yourself
everybody does that to a degree but um he really
as you said danny you really does zero in on the
right things almost immediately and that is just
not something that anyone takes for granted that's
that's some talent right there great and it's
funny there's an outside chance that something
weird happens here if sardosh takes this knight
with the bishop and this check comes in and if
black wonders something like king h7 oh wait
i forgot the knight was even attacking the
mission never mind even this doesn't work because
i was going to go for some fancy thing like this
and highlight exactly like the eval bar said
it's made but the bishop is even hanging so
super tough but anyway there are some maybe
outside chances there's only a minute for sardosh
too so this is oh he did take he took with the
bishop it takes if myth gives check and he moves
the king instead of blocking with the bishop we
could have a wild ending like i just predicted
yeah if myth sees that lobster pincer theme
um and i think myth is going to give the
check on c8 that's really the only thing
he can do here unfortunately i'm worried
that he's just panicking and the chance is
vanishingly small but nonetheless are dosh
stepping up in the critical moment here gotta give
him some credit and b4 by myth that's a really
interesting movie he's distracting the queen
from its defense of the bishop oh my gosh this
okay just to show real quick before we listen
in if the queen takes and this check happens
now there's no bishop d8 black would still be
winning but now you have to see this retreating
move otherwise g6 and you get mated on f8 so
let's listen into myth and see what happens
here but this this could still be a wild
finish below a minute now actually good
um so this gives me what this gives me free
the discover check is gonna be devastating
things aren't as bad as they used to be oh maybe
i lied yep what am i oh wow that's track c5
i don't see five right oh we don't block a pawn
move to a white checkmate there's
still that one checkmate okay
regardless oh it all goes downhill
dude it goes south so fast oh no
good game my guy wow what an
intense game danny that was crazy
good guess what they got another one
fifth that was tough lasting in defeat
that was a lot closer i think than than people i
mean that almost had if he doesn't play queen d4
and and sardoche doesn't check on the next move
this idea of f6 setting up the checkmate was what
we had been looking at for a while that was that
was super wild and i thought we might have a fall
out of your chair uh moment luckily i have a chair
with back support now we've been upgrading the
office a little that i feel a lot better that was
such a smooth transition danny i have no words but
they've got a second game and uh myth has just
put everyone on notice that he is he is here to
play and he is going to deal some blows and he
almost did in this game i mean uh lundwig said
mr beast has got the you know consolation bracket
victory written all over i think myth too because
we know he's he's continuing to grind and get
better throughout the whole event these games
are are really showing uh a different player than
one that we saw first learning the game on his
streams a few weeks ago so all right we're gonna
take a break we have our last game of the day
don't go anywhere it's pogchamps three presented
by grip six final game of the day when we return
hang it man dude the time was ticking i was under
pressure oh no i just needed to use my eyeballs
wait but wasn't i wait
no wait no i couldn't have no i couldn't have
maybe like okay wait hold up maybe i could have
done it let's see where i could have done it
if i would have moved on now now and gone
for this no no i don't have this i think
i don't think i have this ever because i move
pawn he takes and then this just has a slot so
even if i go here i never get that i could get the
check but i don't think i ever get the mate here
does that make sense yeah i
don't think i ever get the mate
check first move on palm
check first check first then move on
oh true check move pawn it's over
yeah dude that's above my
pay grade i'm not gonna lie
there's a gnat as well inside of here
that's kind of bothering driving me
crazy
hard to spot yeah for sure gg
dang especially like i was under pressure as well
like i was running out of time at
this moment so i was just like dude
yeah this this this was actually the play
and then he goes here i go here and then
wait doesn't he just cover with pawn
oh yeah chad he just covers the pawn
and then and then what then you move queen
to f8 okay and then he does what after this
mate and one oh because i go here yeah he does
like this or so he does whatever he does here i
win oh dude yeah i didn't see that that's like
a that's like a checkmate in three i hold up
let's go here do this one two
three
he has no counter to this
he can't kill my pawn in any way can't get my
i guess he could do this but then yeah
he could just do that and then it's
yeah then i can't do that but
then i would have to wait but
then i would my move instead
of doing that would be this
and then he would go i don't know
he could go he would do well then he would
take this and then that would no this pla i
don't think this plan would work but we are
in a better position to win the game though
i think if i'm like this for sure yeah wait
no he does that i still could win off of that
i see yeah we could have won
damn well the more you know
bang game over a little pawn that could
we got next game maybe we could uh take
it off some uh emote only for a little
bit uh let the chess chatters flow in
sorry for disappointing you guys i bet that was
really difficult for a lot of people to look at
but that's like that's a hard thing
to do you would block queen with bush
bishop to prevent check oh oh wait actually
yeah wait no yeah we're completely missing this
in an ideal world i do this he just does that
i lost my queen
easy
blood is analyzing your game that's
very nice of him hope he's enjoying
analyzing my game why don't you look at an
analysis uh you did not have a force mate
and we all deliver on our promises around here
pog champs three presented by grip six look at mr
beast coming through in the clutch he didn't waste
any time donating the ten grand plus apparently
two hundred dollars i don't maybe that's the price
of admission or something i don't know but ten
thousand dollars plus 200 to a charity that is
unconfirmed but this just went down on twitter
um and that was because he bet ludwig that
he would donate 10k so it's pretty bleep and
awesome that that just happened danya damn girl
that is that is amazing that is a lot of zeros
and that was a great match too so uh
all around awesome stuff going on yeah
that is a big number i can't wait to see what else
happens uh throughout this whole next couple weeks
um and to remind everybody what we're doing over
these next couple weeks we're also raising money
for charity uh we still got a lot of time to
reach our goal of a hundred thousand dollars
remember every dollar you donate is matched by
chess.com the the company itself in addition to
the hundred thousand dollar prize for the
players we are putting a hundred thousand
dollars more toward charities that are chosen
by our players and uh it's gonna be split up
based on the prizes they win so whatever whatever
you might be interested in doing we do appreciate
it we see some incredible charities st jude's
chose by mr beast right there uh just because
we were talking about him but amazing charity
shows and as i said some of these are super
super intimate and near and dear to these people's
uh these people's hearts these these celebrities
arts here and uh and so if any of them ring a
bell for you uh we we saw rayne talk about his
uh charity he has with his wife support uh girls
education and all kinds of amazing things in haiti
um yesterday so anyway consider it we do
appreciate use the command charity command
donate and chat if you want to learn more info all
right rocking and rolling into our last game we'd
be strolling oh my god danny stop rhyming people
are watching you wow that was import i'm impressed
i mean if only we had logic here to evaluate
that i know um we throw down some rhymes from
time to time um no we don't actually we only
talk yes pretty much i'm kidding um anyway uh
this is gonna be a lot of fun what you said
and i saw chat talking about it on chess tv
uh exploration time was talking about how
impressive myth was there we saw him at the break
taking time to actually look at that
mate pattern that i showed right with
the f6 queen f8 so he's really putting in the
time after his games to learn and get better
and now he's got a grub to deal with a grub named
after henry grubb and uh sometimes danny i feel
like the name of the opening sort of implies
whether it's good or bad and uh let me just
say that the grub is not on an objective level a
good opening and henry graub is not a bad player
grub also means like a coffin in in russian so
it kind of represents the kind of opening this is
but he's already in a good position because mitt's
last move was not very accurate yeah his first
move was good for the record everyone when when
someone part of the reason the grab isn't good
if we just want to talk principles is because it's
not a move that attacks the center so principally
principally i am i am all over the map today with
my words i apologize uh the principles of grabbing
the center come back and you should play e5 or
d5 so e5 was good but then this move allows the
knight to get kicked around and uh oh it's already
it's already even worse he's losing the knight
and that's the thing with these openings right
they're bad from an objective standpoint but
they can be great at surprise weapons and they
can contain all these vicious traps now a myth
he's got to get it together and he's got to give
that knight up danny for as much as he can that
means taking the pawn on f2 biting the bullet
and doing as much damage as you can let's go
listen into what myth is talking about because
he is considering that i believe this is bad um
okay well he's going to get two pawns this way
listen man if i'm losing a d4 now knight e3 is
actually a really cool move 93 is
actually a super strong move and
black would be winning if i'm losing
i'm getting two pawns out of it
that's really hard that you might
take on f2 you understand me
if i'm losing i'm getting
two pawns out of that bad boy
oh no oh checking he wants to
check oh he goes for a check
yeah but now c3 that puts another piece on fire
now he's in big trouble
all right who do i not want to
hope lose doesn't forget his queen's hanging
yeah a lot of stuff is hanging
three pieces to be exact
actually i don't think he's gonna take
anything he jinxed him oh my lands oh no oh
abort [ __ ] gotta just abort [ __ ] boys ship wow
oh man you know that you know that it was kevin's
influence he's got the famous video where he drew
magnus carlson with the grub kevin bourdain if
you don't know is a good friend i'm teasing he's
kind of the face of chess.com to the french chess
community and he does an awesome job for us here
at this company but he is responsible for this
rob that unfortunately just torched myth and this
this whole idea is how dangerous the grop can be
although sardoche did make a huge mistake
here with d4 if myth had seen 93 everyone
that would have blocked the queen and given
a discovered attack to the bishop here
um again we talk about discoveries is where you
move a piece and you don't even attack with that
piece you attack with a piece behind it um that
was his chance he missed it and unfortunately
actually blundered his queen along the way oh
that hurts oh man yeah that's so frustrating and
you know they all went they went all aboardy the
ship the grab ship including sirdosh i mean i'm on
a roll today it's unequivocal you are spitting
hot fire your rhymes are tight on that mic um
dang right yeah and this is just a queen down
full queen down yeah this is um unfortunately
unfortunate myth and um i know he's got good
coaching he's working with maurice ashley
and others uh but uh anyway like you said
that's the danger of these openings go ahead
and that's that's what chess is you
know it's it's one of those things where
one little thing is wrong for you and you've got
so much to take care of and so much to watch that
unless you're super experienced getting out of
these situations and not blundering more pieces is
one of the hardest skills in chess
because you're so disconcerted
sardo's not playing this great but i mean
he's a queen up basically anything wins
yeah it's funny because the final score is again
not going to be indicative of how close this match
was that first game was moves from going the other
way and seconds they were both under mutual time
pressure this game here it's not to take anything
away from sardosh it's good coaching from kevin
bourdieu and it's an opening he knows well but
but he's not necessarily playing the most accurate
moves he actually even even made a big mistake
earlier as we've highlighted a couple times but
but um you know but he's still going to get the
w here because this is just almost an impossible
position for black to come back in yeah the smooth
bishop h3 that he played might strike people's
weird but he's going to push that g pawn up i
think he can also take the pawn on e5 but i think
the idea was to open that bishop up by pushing
the grub pawn up instead he decides to take on
the take on e5 literally anything is winning
here but ultimately i think that he's probably
going to try to mate black down the h file he's
going to play g5 and bring the queen up to h5
agreed tail population us that was a good
one never heard that one before pushing the
push in the uh the awkward envelope over
to you now dude that is an envelope i'm
very familiar with and bishop h boyd tries
to put that bishop in front of the rook
but here g4 did you fight would be very
very strong opening up that file giving up
sacrificing the groupon but i think he's
emotionally attached to to the grab pawn
yeah it's upon it's a pawn you fall in love with
right you start pushing g4 and you never go back
um yeah brings tears to my eyes i thought pawn
is behind many experiences that i had in my life
i've even got a g4 emote on my
own twitch channel super active
channel twitch.tv slash daniel wrench
definitely worth a follow i stream all the time
uh yeah yeah you're the best streamer in history
in the history of streamers best um the uh all
right queen b3 also not a bad move i mean sardosh
as you said can play almost anything here um
yeah and as do they say on twitch
well saj or white people sad
sad badge but there's saj but i usually am not saj
i'm more mad i'm gonna introduce another word to
the twitch sphere i thought it was sage sage
no but it comes from sad right so it's gotta
be sash but i'm gonna introduce the word madge
which just means um not sad but mad but on twitch
okay i didn't even know right and um got
a lot to learn my contribution to society
actually i stole this from good friend who
coined this word we don't want to revisit
some of the things i had to learn in pog champs
too appropriate and one of the most viral clips
i learned recently i'm not even going to
talk about it i don't want to talk about it
you don't want to talk about it well i'm pretty
mad that you don't want to talk about it and
andrea's capturing another night
oh now everything is falling
yeah this is just tough though i mean honestly as
we said and we were kind of foreshadowing i had
the fear had this feeling when he played bishop
before check that the the attack he would remember
is the most recent one right that's a very easy
mistake to make as a chess player when you make
a move and someone attacks a piece you're
mainly focused on that piece forgetting that
you already kind of got yourself in a world of
trouble earlier and so once this queen was lost um
as you said it's uh
all over red rover some myth right over and
uh and one of the things that we noticed about
stronger players is typically a lot of players at
this level and again it's no shame but this is why
it's it's you know it's a learning experience
but a lot of times from zero to 14 even 1500
you know strength can vary wildly blunders can be
made all over the place but i think the difference
between the stronger players in the event is when
they get a winning position they're very unlikely
to blow it right and you see some of them play
with the confidence of ludwig today the pre-move
to checkmate right i mean it was awesome and i
think sardoce is going to be one of those guys
where if you're going to get them you know you
can't you can't go down this kind of material
yeah i mean definitely set the gold
standard with uh with that technique but
the problem is yeah you're up a queen up a
piece and it really the sad thing is it doesn't
matter even the specific moves you make um
as long as you defend against the threats
uh because you know because there's just too
much extra stuff and you're absolutely right i
think you hit the nail on the head danny where
it it's not that you know sardosi doesn't make
mistakes it's all about the consistency
though he doesn't blunder too much and
even if he's not playing great he's not going
to shoot himself in the foot too many times
yep make this is playing quickly uh or he's trying
to speed up now because he's down down to four
minutes um instantly broke back to c8 now the grab
pawn is moved to unleash yet another discovered
attack apparently we're doing basic tactical
themes here today unleashing an attack behind it
yep there it goes 10 moves after i thought it
would be played but he doesn't i'm afraid myth
might take that pawn see that's another thing
where you tunnel vision the thing that's hanging
but that's what where i've been impressed by myth
and well of course i have to jinx him as always
yeah but he is his logic is impressive
that doesn't take anything away from him
yep oh man well he's uh we're going
to have interviews with the players
obviously so don't go anywhere the day is not
over yet we will check in with them and again
the uh the pogchamps event is young and still
a lot a lot of chess to be seen from these guys
let's tune in with myth here and get his
final thoughts as this game comes to a close
can help me i need help listen if there are any
chess.com viewers send help send help i'm down
bad i don't know if they have my audio on but
look at my lips i'm down horrendous i am down
bad send backup send the cia send the fbi
send the men in black i don't send somebody
oh no oh death is beth is among
us boys the si the ship is sinking
all has failed us this game
things aren't looking too hot
all right woman woman and
uh woman and children first
get in the like get in the wraps
get in the wraps take refuge
yeah this is a fitting a fitting uh
way of describing the situation oh
not over nice yeah i think
stardust is enough pieces here
that was fun
again the final scoreboard and
the way that game went i mean
some of the games can be misleading like that not
not to say against hardocious and a super strong
player but it definitely was kind of off the
rails in an unfair way for myth early and there
was there was no slowing down the uh the train
there right no for sure sardocis his grinding is
coming through he's consistent he's solid he's
he's a a serious player and uh myth uh myth did
the very best that he could and that first game
was super competitive danny uh he's going to uh
he's going to fire some bullets in this tournament
for sure all right well there may be no slowing
down sardosh but there's also no slowing down grip
six our official presenting sponsor uh reminder
you you gotta go to grip6.com right now you can
also go to go.just.com script6 but either way
you're going to use the pogchamps 20 promotion
code to get 20 off i highly recommend the socks
i've had no shame about it people don't believe
me i tweeted earlier before the match started that
uh that i was wearing the socks um but again
they're a belt company first the belts are
awesome no flap no bulk right there the belt
is comfy head over to grip6.com you'll get
a chance to win that custom chest set don't go
anywhere we have interviews we'll be right back
you will be surprised other
times you surprise your opponent
but overall um i think for instance here i
know this is this is already like it's not
pleasant but where would you move the night
what other squares do you have for the night
um d5 or better square for the knight down before
d5 is safe e4 is fine um or um g4 yes so you
have g4 e4 d5 let's compare these two because
those seem to be the most natural when it comes
to going toward the center you place your knight
immediately in the center so that would make sense
that we are going to one of these squares but
one is a lot better than the other um if
you have your knight here and i want you to
visualize it yeah because night jumps are those
tricky ones and we can still always practice if
the knight is on e4 can you find a move for
white that would make sure that that knight
is attacked and can not jump to any square without
being captured we want to trap the knight on e4
so what what would be white's move yes yeah i want
you to picture the the night uh your night on e4
and i'd like you to find a move for why that
would trap it the night because it looks like
a good spot but there's a move a very annoying
one by white that would attack it and capture it
i don't think the night is safe
on any square after going there
but you're saying what what is
the attack it would it be just
yeah pawn that's that's the solution but you
you were immediately understanding that oh
like from here it can cannot go to any of these
squares so this is something to take into account
when you choose where to place your pieces is
that once it's there does it have where to go
and in this case this knight has no jumps
it has no moves so as active as it looks
there there will be games where the
knight is very well placed there
but that's why everything has to has to be
observed in the context of the rest of the
pieces that knight could be a beast in another
game and in this game it's a very clumsy piece
because it has nowhere to jump to okay so you
are right d3 attacks the knight and wherever the
knight goes it's trapped yeah okay yeah what about
knight to d5 is it the same situation or do you
have moves from d5 for the knight if in case it's
attack because white could attack it right right
here um yeah there are more places for it to go
so it means that our knight is not
in trouble on d5 right yeah amazing
so for next time even if the position is
unpleasant because in this case normally your
knight is not chased away just try to try to see
what are some of the better alternatives because
even if it's not denied but any other piece if you
have already developed a piece try not to put it
back to the initial square because then it's then
it's something that didn't actually do anything
yeah so it took us one move to get the knight
out to six and another move to go back which
means that you spent two moves and the knight
is on the initial square that's why these moves
um as much as we can we try to avoid them because
it loses remember when i was trying to explain
to you what is time in chess and not on the
clock but time in the position yeah this is
time because it was two moves oh yeah a temple yes
it was two moves to move the knight back and forth
and it's on the same square so you're gonna
need a third move to move it again excellent
excellent i like i appreciate you helping me go
through the the possibility of if a blunder hat
like this happens again because that's yeah
that's the type of training i hadn't even
like i feel like a lot of times i look at my games
and i i figure out what would have been the best
move instead of the blunder but that's like
next level to think about what's the next move
after you've made a blunder yes it's important
that just because this move i'm sure that in this
moment you sense that oh something is not quite
right it's not exactly our setup but even if it
happens to you it's not the end of the world
so there's always there's always a way to put
up more resistance you should always try to find
the strongest response even when the position is
not the coolest not the nicest it's this
is far from being decisive it's just
an unpleasant move and yes he has even if you have
the knight here he would have these tricks that he
pushes the pawn and the rook is attacked so it's
not easy to counter these kind of surprise attacks
it comes out of the blue it's literally move five
and you're already being attacked by all of these
pieces the pawn and the bishop so um i just need
you to to to understand this part too yes what you
said that even though there will be occasions
when your opponent surprises you sometimes
in the opening sometimes in the middle game it's
also possible that you miss an idea in the middle
game at a later stage so it's not necessarily an
opening preparation thing it's more about just
the mentality that what i told you about okay
moves it's also okay to miss ideas it's also
okay to miss moves so i just need you to be like
super chill about oh i missed it okay my bad but
next page blank page this is the situation how do
i put up the most resistance possible got it okay
yeah and well the way we are learning about these
for instance these night jumps to compare them
it's not only for this exact position i just
want you to to use this kind of thinking overall
in general in your games because you may
not have this position in your next matches
but you could have a similar situation where it's
a choice of where do i place the knight do i want
to go back or will i try to move it to a more
active square especially if it's the center and
what's the difference between e4 and d5 where is
the knight safe we want to keep our pieces safe d5
excellent excellent job i think i
was being told that we were on the
the main broadcast so hello to everybody
these like these uh these uh put you on blast in
front of a hundred thousand people without warning
we got to be on our best behavior
at all times yeah of course it's t5
you've just spotted 95 so i think we were in the
right moment we can be talking about about series
in the meantime and there for those five minutes
something instructive you're doing an amazing job
michelle and we are here to learn from this game
because it wasn't an easy one and after e6 again
let's say you already had the knight there let's
say this is bad but i want you to again put up
the most resistance possible what's the main
threat of your opponent okay so main thread is
bishop takes on h8 so my thought now that this
has happened a a better move could have been f6
to get one possible pawn out of the way of this
annoying pawn on the sixth rank and also block um
the bishop excellent blocks the diagonal saves
the rook and stuff actually i believe was like
you should have gone f6 and i was like oh yeah
i didn't hear this part when he told you but i i
i was switching back and forth because i
was like on your channel i can hear your
thought process i was mainly watching your stream
don't tell the show i'm going to be on the show
tomorrow and such but like oh can't wait to see
you see it from your perspective i think i'll
be on on thursday too when you are playing
no no no that's no pressure because it's the
same it's the same tournament and i would be
watching regardless whether i'm casting or not i'm
watching so you did very well yesterday but yes f6
that saves the rook and then this pawn alone is
not that big of a deal what's your next move if
your opponent doesn't touch the spawn if that pawn
stays there what do you do let's say i move here
and we are back here pogchamps3 we're
now joined by both of our players
we've got myth we've got andreas on audio thanks
for being with us again guys hello hi everyone
yeah yeah myth let me let me start with you we
got we got the chessboard up what was a critical
position in the in in the first game which was
a super intense game you both got under time
pressure danya and i were super nervous over
here we had no idea what was going to happen
take us through your thought process
though because when the queen went to a5
i was singing your praises myth that a lot of
times in your games you immediately are looking
at your opponent's threats first which a lot
of people don't do that they do the opposite
but then after that you did see that you
could take b7 but kind of got away from it
and dismissed it eventually eventually went with
a different move like what why did you end up not
taking the b7 pawn when you first saw it hold on
we've lost we've lost your audio myth one second
oh sorry all right you're sorry
yeah yeah honestly i have no idea
it happened it's okay it happens that way
sometimes yeah i dish it out to inexperience
and just second guessing myself the pressure
of being you know in the tournament setting
in the tournament event and uh yeah i think
that's all that's all i really chop it down to
i don't think there's any other excuse you know
inexperience and and and uh second guessing myself
not being confident in the move that i think is
right when i think it's right you know as the
first game was so intense like i was i actually
didn't even see the rook i was so so stressed and
panicked when when you played so aggressive at
first and i focused on my plan and i felt like
i could defend if you would commit to my my king
and i was like okay well i will focus on my things
and i will let him do stuff i i hope it works but
finally it works but i i already think suku you
are really close like maybe some some 10 hours of
training to to beat me on the first game for sure
but the second game sadly you had
no preparation for this grub and
it was it was a bit harder i guess before we
even talk about the grav in this first game uh
donny and i were we're on the edge of our
seat right here there was there was almost
a potential tactic with queen c8 f6 donna
you want you want to take us through that
yeah so and and myth i was impressed with the fact
that you were analyzing this afterwards so this
check on c8 could follow and then uh andreas maybe
you saw that then the king runs to h7 which is not
the only move but then you play f6 check and uh
black can take the bishop and that's the saving
grace because if black goes g6 then the queen
slides over to f8 and that's a lobster pincer
so you know this was close until the very end and
andres you played very well in the final stage of
the game to sort of make sure that your king was
safe but it was intense as well we had no we had
no time actually we were both at two minutes or
one and it was so stressful to actually find the
good move and not blunder in this situation like
wow damn at that point in the game i remember
even like at this very phase i was looking at
the time and i was like oh man 30 seconds left
i just gotta move something and i don't
have time to like i don't think i was
um i don't think i'm i was like good enough i
literally told myself like i'm not good enough
to to come up or think about the right thing at
the right time i just need to move so i don't
just lose time at the time we had one minute
left and i just i just thought about my my
code with swift tough then he told me
just move the pc then it will go well so
well speaking of your coach sardosh before we move
on from that obviously uh mr blitzstream himself
kevin bourdee gets credit for the grub this is
uh yeah it worked out here obviously man crazy
he just played against magnus carson himself
with maybe 600 you know under him and he
actually beat him with a grub so i guess
this is some some fun to play and actually i
i learned chess with that opening so it forced me
to play really tactic already mostly with tactics
so i can't really just position my pieces and
win i need to find a way to crush my opponent so
this is how i learn chess this is why i
struggle so much with close position and
this is why i force myself to play london
system to actually grind and learn lunches yeah
i think that's not a bad idea to actually play
grub to launches you might be the first but that's
that's really cool i guess if it's good enough
for magnus it's good enough for myth so maybe
you're in good company with the world champion
the grub is the grub is hard to handle um but
you know seriously man i know you said yourself
chalk it up to inexperience but but i mean that
in a good way that there were a lot of things we
listened in on you a lot and there were a lot of
times your thought process was like totally on
point and i just want to say that because there
were there were moments where and that game came
down to the wire where we were we were singing
your praises and i know that you know where this
event is heading i just uh every every time we we
watch you stream here and play chess it's you're
just getting better every time man so just want to
say that thank you liz man paul champs four and
our next match i have a few days so i'm gonna
i'm gonna you know nose to the grindstone and
hopefully you know i could pull off a few dubs
against nico but then you know it from here and
until then i like chess as a game i really want to
stick to it and uh maybe maybe i'll see you guys
next year you know yeah but it's a lot absolutely
the way you're doing right now for sure
great games guys thank you thanks a lot guys
all right well um you heard it everyone's
already talking about pogchamps four i mean
first of all it may not be next year maybe
maybe it'll be this year but i will say that
there's been so much positivity from
this especially this particular group and
um i know a lot of them off stream have been
talking that way um and uh and on stream as well
so sardoche takes it continues to impress and that
was our final score of today but let's preview
tomorrow speaking of someone who's already been
talking about pogchamps four pokemane has been
obsessed with chess she'll be back against xqc but
to kick things off we have rubius and negron you
nico and benji fishy omg's are snaps dania which
match are you most looking forward to tomorrow
well i've i've got to go with xqc against pokemon
the others are going to be super interesting too
but i'm so excited to see how much xqc has
improved and i've heard about pokemans grinding
as well so danny that's going to be a marquee
matchup and that's i'm going to have my my
eyes glued to the screen no agreed and you know
obviously xuc got the job done against rubius
with the 2-0 victory but those games were super
close right i mean anyone who watched yesterday
uh if you didn't shame on you check out the vaude
but uh rubius xuc rubius even had a mate one it
could have gone anyway so i i think pokey and and
xqc are going to have a crazy match i'm with you
that that's the one that's uh hard to turn away
from of course all the others look crazy too nico
and benji fishy and rubios and negroni so speaking
of crazy man it's been a wild day how you feeling
wow four hours three and a half hours have gone by
and a flash we've got so many ups and downs and i
have to second what you said earlier danny just
amazing high quality performances all across the
board whether by the favorites or by um first time
players i think everybody just put their hearts
out on the line today and produced some amazing
chess yeah and i know we keep talking about it
but it has been something that i think was partly
inspired by the queen's gambit i was teasing
jimmy mr beast about it but there's a there was
something about the the the vibe of coming to
this event that it wasn't just that people were
inspired to play chess i think i think the series
it was like people were inspired to learn and get
better and we've seen that and we've seen so many
people just diving into lessons and coaching and
it's been a ton of fun so it makes me think that
where we're going from now to the end
of this event over the next couple weeks
we're going to see everyone continue to get
better maybe ludwig's right maybe that consolation
bracket will just be nuts right regardless of
who's in it in terms of how good they've gotten
so um anyway amazing stuff want to give one last
shout out to all of our subscribers there's been
a ton of you today and tons of people also
throwing in some cash toward our charity
goals which are big we're going to continue to
get there we really appreciate your support and
we hope you can see continue seeing that being
driven up to the team the crew working hard all
of our mods hardly working working hard no
they're all working hard um to my partner
well to my partner as well so you know who's gonna
is gonna be the first to say uh mean things about
the other that's the question no one's gonna
say mean things i mean um thanks thanks to
everybody that was a lot of fun danny it was
a lot of fun thanks to everyone for tuning
in and we will see you tomorrow for another
day of pogchamps three presented by grip six
the one you want and something um in a kremling
showed to me um you know was like the left to
right scanning of the board to double check
protected pieces which in this game all of
the games was very helpful to me and what i
think i learned here is i need to be doing that
earlier because i thought we're in the opening
blah blah blah not like not like the opening
is full autopilot but i definitely don't think
to use that until i'm in like not like a pickle
but like what what move should i make next i
don't know okay let me start by scanning things
and i think like it's just a good it's like doing
your dishes you know i just need to do the dishes
i'm glad that she told you about this i'm gonna
learn i think i'm gonna apply that too from from
anna because i also say about the unprotected
pieces but i think it's it's a good idea that
if you have this so so much of a method that
it's like a scan from left to right yeah that's
new to me too so i'm learning because the the
unprotected piece is extremely important the
king and unprotected pieces and when we when
we did our puzzle training at the very start
and just in general to spot motives and ideas i
i think you remember that i told you about the
the king the unprotected pieces and the
unfortunately placed pieces those three
categories but yeah i like that from
now on you're gonna scan the board
from the opening on because you are right it
can be as early as move four five six that
something is hanging so it's good if you if you
pay more attention to unprotected pieces i agree
queen to c2 would have been a good idea even even
like this again mistakes will happen but it's good
that you then adjust to the new situation new
situation being oh yeah we lost the pawn but
the rook is hanging yeah so you move the knight
away because that's the only way to guard it even
if it loses a second pawn the rook is priority
so you did the right thing by moving the knight
queen takes c3 and bishop b5 check you
realize that now your bishop is hanging
so you moved it to b5 i
think that's a good reaction
because it wasn't so easy to guard it what would
happen if you guard this bishop with the queen
and i'm not going to move it i just want you
to visualize it what's wrong with that move
rook's hanging the rock is hanging yeah our queen
is too busy our queen cannot handle everything a
same would be about queen c2 and these are very
easy blunders this would be actually very easy
to blunder because when something is guarded as
of now then you feel like it's not in danger and
you could easily move your queen away to guard
something that's now in danger so you end up
losing more than what you have protected i'm glad
that you have spotted it instantly so we ain't
blundering we and blundering that rook bishop
b5 is one of the best reactions for that reason
even our knight with this pin so you didn't have
much of a choice bishop b5 to get out of this a
very dangerous situation for the bishop bishop
to d7 here you had the choice to take but in